rebonjour tout le monde bonsoir tout le
monde ça va démarrer dans trois minutes
c'est le speech s les amis mamediarov
contre wesley so mam et qui va se faire
défoncer ce soir les mecs
j'annonce je prends des risques avant le
match je donne mon prono le no fake sera
prouvée au cas où mais j'annonce une
grosse victoire de wesley so après c'est
moins sûr qu'ils arrière j'avais donné
100 pour soi anaqua et je m'étais pas
trompé je pense qu'on joue le match 100
fois il ya sans victoire ce soir non sur
vous ce match sans foi y aura passant à
0 pour wesley so ça va être chaud ça va
être ouest les shows ce match et
mamediarov qui n'a pas son prénom âge
j'ai envie de te dire pourquoi
mamediarov contre voit ses sauts j'ai
envie de dire pourquoi ya pas ton prénom
on ne sait pas on ne s'est pas entendu
des échos des patients et des nombreux
sur ce sur ce live
elle famose au live tu as un pied déjà
qu'on soit bien live on sait pas on sait
pas mais normalement oui le match qui
débute dans quelques secondes
maintenant donc un peu un petit peu de
regarder à yahoo qui est live la veille
caro a commenté le match et cote
cantareil car en fait c'est génial
il commande sur sa chaîne perso c'est
fou ça c'est étrange
c'est étrange parce que il est en sus
arrière de jouer il commente aujourd'hui
c'est très étrange
effectivement mais je suis étonné on ne
sait pas on ne sait pas salut le cnes
salue ton ton salut avec vers son alex
perd son imac y est hein je te vois
beaucoup sur les lives alex je suis
content que sûrement sauvé la et 20 mai
je m'inquiète pour toi tu apprécies tu
es cité site étudiant quoi ça va mais
sinon je m'inquiète pas pourquoi je me
vois pas là il en faisait que c'est que
ce bordel mais bordel j'ai le droit
d'être live
attends je vais t'arracher avec
bitstream tient et salua les taux de
qena
je m'attends au c'ur bitstream roseaux
pourquoi pas donc
bah ouais bon jour en vie et en mettant
au jour une maintenant aux stands je
fais un peu ce que je veux aussi en même
temps le host est fait
la rue ans peut-être un poil jeter un
oeil au tableau au nom à chaque fois on
se fait avoir avec le tableau national
alors je suis très excité manson
écouteurs au bureau bon ça va alors tu
me rassures bon je sais pas si ça va
être un grand match les mecs je vous
promets rien honnêtement ça va être
mieux qu'hier c'est sûr mais je vous
promets pas un jeu c'est pas autant et
hier je savais que ça allait être un
massacre
c'était clair et évident autant
aujourd'hui c'est pas sur le guerrier le
stream de hikaru était une catastrophe
quand le title hier ben en fait j'ai
entendu parler n'y a personne qui a
vraiment regarder tu peux nous éclairer
lugar du coup ça avec plaisir juste la
gueule sous le vent et se moquer des
partis de droite 8 on avait droit fil a
fini troisième c'est la chaîne 10 belles
affiches kalma sur le papier oui mais ma
mère qui à mon avis va être bien
derrière on va voir c'est une belle
affiche mais bah je vous donne vraiment
mon vrai sentiment je pourrais vous
vendre vous la sueur vendre je pense que
soe au dessus mais après bref vu que tu
as eu des échos l'ougass tu peux nous
nous éclairer un peu savaient que ça
avec plaisir et donc moi je pars demain
pour moscou si vous voulez me suivre sur
twitter je vais sûrement twitté faire de
l'insta g j'ai envie de faire le con
très souvent des vidéos sur twitter et
machin un peu un peu débile
en fait j'aime pas les stories je vais
rester réchauffe que c'est l'immédiateté
stories qui c'est bon faut que je chante
les parties quand elle débute
tu as peur pour moi je veux voir ma
belle famille jeu voire vlad
ouais mais j'ai lu ahmad ahmad ahmad
mais j'ai pas sujet lui qui l'avait
accusé aussi quelqu'un de triche vulgar
en plus un mec qui est qui et qui est un
regular des arénas mais après je
m'attends tellement à tout maintenant tu
as tellement de gens qui font n'importe
quoi les scènes back des machins et on
l'a bien vu par le passé donc je
m'attends tellement à tous
prénom franchement la vidéo je vais mise
en ligne la sueur sur l'objectif 1900
était pas mal donc petit gang dames on
me dit et ça les matches sept records du
corps massif le swan games et sega
museum eu beaucoup de parts à qui les
jours abandonné assez vite hier ils ont
enchaîné les parties
donc il joue h 4 ici donc on regarde du
côté mavs est pour le moment alors
attendez c'est un bon bidane tout ce
qu'il ya de plus normal et il envoie h4
assez tôt alors qu'havas léger sainteté
est ce que ces nuages 4g cateau t on
mais qui est bien avec des velléités
offensives donc saluer adrian cham 1
savez vous qu on peut parier sur les
matchs j ai couru en speech est je viens
de voir ça en cherchant les stades
documentation sur quel site du coup à
l'exerçons ça c'est lui c'est une info
qui peut être intéressante 1 après de là
à partir de france on peut pas forcément
jouer sur les sites et/ou et puis faites
attention de ses moins de 18 ans tout ça
tout ça quoi vous n'avez pas le droit et
tout mais ça peut être une info a lâché
un set ça que je pourrais faire depuis
la russie jusque là par curiosité
c'était quoi la côte de wesley so parce
que je levais grand favori sur la came
c'est le nom de hikaru soummam et
non moi je vois bien les médias rohff
bon en tout cas cette fois leur parti
c'est intéressant on a un pion qui est
parti à angers 5 dont kim anh une
attaque éclair emma mais qui joue grand
roque donc les rangs quand on attaque
fortement sur l'aide faut réagir au
centre ou sur la l'opposé pourquoi pas
mais là ma mais je pense qu'il va faire
du simple il va faire dam des deux dames
f4 h4 je vois pas de contre indication
de toute façon tu vas aller mater en
force un tas tout fait pour je ne sais
pas poser trop de questions à ce
moment-là parti je serai juste à les
mener mon attaque mais c'est vrai que
surtout 8,3 et fuite il faudra mater on
a souvent vu avec fap qui influent g7
comme ça ça défend des biens à sur
marathon bête et du coup tu connais la
côte juste par curiosité
c'est intéressant ouais on sait pas
excéder ses excès de ses poumons c'est
pas de toute façon comme je le disais
tout à l'heure sur le stream sur
internet on peut toujours avoir des
soupçons sur tout le monde et même en
vrai d'ailleurs mais sans preuve on peut
rien faire donc soit on limite les
tournois sur internet avec de l'argent
on voit quand on sait qu'ils sont réglo
soit on est mal mais déjà quand les gens
sont pas obligées de stream et sur leur
propre ordinateur c'est un problème si
tu fais un truc où les gens même si tu
as les caméras bon là c'est parce qu'on
est vraiment sûr mais sinon même si t'as
que les caméras avec les mecs peuvent
donnons pas à screen à screenshot leur
leur écran déjà c'est déjà dangereux
mais bon c'est une variable on le sait
il faut voilà c'est tout c'est qu'ils
touchent un peu c'est sa caméra parce
qu'il fait là sur 24 a clairement fait
retour au 1/8 crois pas il va attendre
d'un match qu'at-il fait pour huit dames
achète pour affûter ya pas moyen de
mater mais bon tu peux ramener du monde
tu peux faire [ __ ] en c4 ramener un
cavalier e 5 il a mené un quart ayant eu
quatre peut-être bénéfices
donc 24 moncayo quatre cartes moquer du
cavalier ou cathy frac avait lieu
qu'avec à traquer des 5
l'aca est intéressant donc sur damage 4e
tour des huit juste pour bien montrer
d'un match à trois fuites et le roi
s'échappe donc cavalier 4 ça peut être
une idée dame prend 1 et ou un truc
comme ça on menace ma tondeuse
donc on menace maths en fait en un mais
c'est les noirs qui frappe en premier
semble-t-il donc il a fait fou prend ses
cafés b5 mais maintenant cavalier ou
quatre qui on prend et cavaliers a aussi
ses joies peut-être je vais mettre un
coup d'ordi les mecs ça m'intrigue qui
avait lieu quatre vingt cavaliers 4 sa
gagne et l'ordi l'avait pas vu
d'ailleurs baissé qui a valu à vis ça ça
m'a t on c'est dommage qu'il ait raté ça
franchement c'est dommage d'avoir raté
ça mais moi je les ai vus et lord il
donnait pas en plus
c'est un guy surtout dommage que dès que
quelqu'un fait une bonne partie
honnêtement il ya suspicion c'est triste
ouais après pour te dire franchement
souvent quand on soupçonne franchement
grandement quelqu'un il ya neuf chances
sur dix que ce soit le cas ou huit
chances sur 10 mai mais bon je parle pas
sur une partie mais quand tu soupçonnes
depuis un moment qu'il ya pas mal de
tournois machin la plupart du temps ça
s'avère aiderez mais après c'est pas une
raison pour faye a pas deux premières
pas de preuve c'est tout tu me demandes
si tous âges un tour prend f3 tourache
huit fois je suis damage 4 c'est
possible de parer de maths je vais
mettre un petit coup d'ordi oui c'est
possible grâce à sa fougue quatre jours
avant ça peut être jolie fée tourage 3
ou c'est beau pourquoi je crois qu'à
réaliser deux français deux dames 1
c'est joli ça
mais qui va commenter c'est fabien qui
prendra mon rôle est sûr à la fin on va
fermer
mais maintenant est ce qu'ils les six
gagnants que ça
tourbes et 8 peut être arriver mais il
va faire 1 3
ouais ok c'est pas possible d'avoir de
preuves donc c'est très facile mais à 3h
adam prend 1,3 pardon c'est pas possible
d'avoir de preuve non plus donc c'est
pour ça que c'est très simple de bruges
est un don qui lui faisait une double
attaque et maintenant tu es tour des
huit dames b 2 twh 4 surtout il peut se
retrouver ma came to reprend dame prend
fou prend tout reprend dame prend tout
reprend échec et il va perdre g5 à la
fin il aura les pions a et b mais
normalement ça va pas suffire
elle atteint même pas être team qui me
mène ne pas faire d'un problème de food
et 5 très bons coups de la part de
wesley qui gardent leur oif m
c'est quoi ça ah c'est rien c'est juste
il avait prévu trois g7
mam est là qui a fait une mauvaise
partie puisque cav a lieu quatre pour un
joueur de son niveau ce que j'ai vu tout
à l'heure et je vérifie alors dit
c'était assez rudimentaire a calculé
donc mauvaise partie de ma mémé c'est ça
je pense que je sais pas me semble
danser speech s il prend un peu par
dessus la jambe je vais pas me pape a
prié les joues on va voir j'espère qu'il
va me faire mentir mais pour moi il les
prend beaucoup trop tranquille c'est ce
pitch s et pour moi il est juste trop
tranquillement
heureusement les vacances trop de ce
crime tu le stream à tanger peut-être
pas le follow sur les joueurs
bizarrement si tu as et une superbe
contrôle de la qualité prime sur la
quantité mais je suis pas je suis pas
partie de ceux qui font le plus de
stream après 1
je me contente de faire un dustry
personnel sur ma chaîne perso et et
après - cgt commandes pour czech comme
pour l'estrie mais c'est différent sur
ma chaîne perso je fais partie des
streamer qui stream le moins je vois un
stream et 5 6 heures par semaine pas
plus j'ai pas fait le title tous dès
hier par exemple ce que j'avais pas
envie
donc tu vois j'aurais peut-être envie de
me faire me faire les arénas le vendredi
c'est possible ce même très possible
alors parti numéro 2 on va voir comment
réagit mal mais qu'il ya une bonne
position
champlain qui ça reste une compétition
amicale mais il ya des joueurs qui
prennent plus au sérieux au delà il ya
quand même beaucoup de compétition
amicale qui jouent déjà ou semi amical
quoi il ya quand même un titre en jeu et
puis c'est quand même assez sympa comme
compet donc ya quand même beaucoup de
joueurs qui la prenne au sérieux mais ma
mais il m'a vraiment l'air d'avoir du
mal je sais pas vous dire qu'on a acquis
par le mât mais écoutons c'est pas dur
de savoir d'ailleurs mais bon
s'inquiète pas il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas de souci avec ces personnes là
alors justin de vérifier un truc pour
que tout soit bon ok haut niveau c'est
un genre de récit genre de récit avec
une genre de structure est indienne avec
les noirs c'est un peu bizarre quand et
comment as a way ils ont fait une est
indienne avec 40 g iii et finalement il
a joué avec des 4 5 et 5 ans je suis
quand je suis revenu sur la position ça
me semblait être entre deux entre deux
choses un peu bizarre donc le fou qui
arrivant à 3 4 qui a aidé deux des cinq
tours h5 d'accord voit pas
donc la france a fait une structure de
type française à couleurs inversées bien
évidemment cavaliers fuite
kamali eux deux
s'ils reviendraient fca tuera g5 et veut
pas faire un virage 4 d'accord il veut
il veut dès que le cavalier arrive en f4
avoir g5
on va revoir dès demain il y aura un
beau match puisque raffy route jacques
contre aronian ce sera un match très
sympa à suivre ces fables qui commentera
je sait plus à quelle heure c'est je
crois que c'est 18h aussi ou 16 heures
donc j'ai quatre jouer car il ya six
mois il contrôle bien à 15 f k du coup
moins sûr cavaliers f4 il sera obligé de
prendre 2 e
ce qui n'a pas envie de faire il est
bien enfermer wesley et s'ils jouent
avec left reste toujours dangereux ci
prend prend il peut pas rentrer sur la
colonne s'est donc il veut pas utiliser
sa dalle il fait tourner il va préparer
f3 pour se libérer au centre qui va
probablement jouer maintenant food et 6
il faut 5 c'est super bien joué ça c'est
très bien joué de la part de wesley qui
va réussir à utiliser les fous de la
française en le mettant à eux cinq et on
peut même parfois jouer avec ses 5 dans
ces cas la frmbb et quatre à quatre
baies 5
parce qu'on s'est débarrassé du croate
du fou
d'un bep 2 il peut vouloir jouer avec
damas trois il faut aussi vouloir
préparer des quatre des cinq comme ça
mais foutez si c'était vraiment bien
joué c'était vraiment une belle idée
cavaliers projet qu'a donc mam et qui
envoie donc ça fait plaisir puis on
prend après je vois pas d' attaque parce
qu'il ya le foot et 6 qui couvrent je
pense que c'est complètement pipeau
après ça peut être dur à gérer c'est
vrai mais fou des 6 me paraît tellement
fort ça aurait été plus fort s'il avait
fait que tant que le fou était bloqué en
a trois fois f4 mais je vois pas comment
les noirs peuvent percer parce que tu
peux pas rentrer sur noir et tu vas pas
pouvoir faire que le boulot sur blanc
propre et même à l'eau h 2 peut-être et
pour jouer du tour g1 est chassé donc il
veut forcer les échanges pour rentrer
sur blanc mais même un coup comme roy h1
et mes cahiers prend en main donc là il
repart vers le centre
quand il a raison de repartir vers le
centre sur quel point il fera du caurroy
programme ce qui est plutôt intelligent
c'est peut-être pas si idiot ce
sacrifice quand même de ma mère
ça m'a paru pipeau de base mais c'était
peut-être pas du tout pipeau
alors comment ça va évoluer
qui est prêt à prendre clairement qu'il
fait c'est 5
c'est intéressant ça
très intéressant puisqu'il veut prendre
comme ça très intéressant parce que
lorsque quelqu'un qui est pro 1re on
apprend et puis on prend ça peut être tu
peux jouer prise prise est prise à rêver
tu vas te faire tu vas t'en reprendre
une petite ici mais a fait cavalier g1
j'ai 5 x 5 ça c'est logique
j'ai pas pris une affaire g5
il est peut-être cardiaque site échec
dans la marne de tout à l'heure à la fin
la fosse avec surprise de 5 prises au
sacré non ça va aller pour ça va aller
pour et ses sauts il va reprendre du tu
vas peut-être prononcé huit
intermédiaire
ouais je comprends qu'un maillage de
maths mais cavaliers suite le fait
supprimer dans tous les cas après
cavaliers gien il reste qu'elle vit un
g5 qui reste pas du tout envie ce qui a
valu d'ailleurs il s'est fait supprimer
ouais mais un temps est-ce qui peut pas
prendre prendre prendre prendre prendre
prendre prendre prendre prendre et tour
ses huit c'est ça l'idée attention il
faudra tout reprendre et 4 parce que ça
peut rentrer dans un truc comme ça
dames g4 sûrement pas si simple ça
rentrait l'attend d'une manière x ou y
mais s'y prend il peut prendre là aussi
intermédiaire pardon j'avais oublié
pouvait prendre angers cet intermédiaire
ça c'était l'autre choix de variantes ça
il ya plein de pièces emprise partout et
là il peut prendre prendre et ours et 8
mais c'est peut-être pas terrible et
noir beaucoup de pions bordélique
opposition
cas 8 quand même
il va pouvoir échanger une perte de
tours
il fait des six intermédiaire en premier
fou prend des six il va prendre trois
assez bien joué ça et ils forcent
échange des dames et il va ramener le
fou versé 8 hausse est magnifique et
foulée tout reprend est fou c'est 8 et
gagne un pion là-bas ou pas d'ailleurs
peut-être doit commencer par cavalier f3
et maintenir la pression et cavaliers
des quatre maintenant ils parcourent
vous évite maintenant il faut prend 17
rivard essayer de ramener le flou sur
cette diagonale
ben c'est bien joué a faim il y aurait
il va arrive à passer par derrière
agayev 5 c'est la gaffe assez lagaf ada2
air pour wesley mais quelle quel niveau
de jeu pour les laisse aux caniveaux de
jeu pour les sauts impressionnants dans
le dans le petit jeu tactique par la ccl
pas c'est pas du tout la même chose que
ce qu'on avait cuillère c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment des baux échec
aujourd'hui c'est des belles parties et
on repart pour ce g4 h4 c'est
intéressant
mais ça fait plaisir de voir des belles
parties comme ça est-ce qu'il va répéter
qu'un ep 4 ici aussi fait le cavalier
4,1 à voir si fait le cavalier e 4 k
jouer et la foux prend ses 4 c'était
bien joué
b si ces cavaliers 4 et carioca de
gagner sur le champ non il le rate
alors là honnêtement là honnêtement je
suis je suis je suis vraiment choqué
parce que je l'avais honnêtement je les
gelées vu ce coup j'ai vu sens ordinaire
devant l'ordi ne donne pas de base avec
un relief si c'est tout âge suite
là je suis quand même étonné raté un
truc comme ça deux fois d'affilée
je sais pas dans le chat si vous êtes et
donner ou pas mais c'est étonnant
c'était quand même pas
c'était quand même pas sorcier non enfin
ça m'a pas paru sorcier en tout cas ça
n'avait rien d'incroyable
c'est vraiment étonnant donc on va voir
comment ça continue cette fois ci je
pense qu'il est plus ou moins obligés de
le prendre ce cahier sur les lycées
n'étions pas étonné ouais ça ça
m'étonnerait que vous ne soyez pas en
fait je vous le dis franchement ça
m'étonnerait que vous ne soyez pas
étonné
un nouveau cas ralliée à 26
mais il est mal à west et sauge pas pour
y répète cette variante
là ils peuvent prendre du cavalier 5 et
pranger 6e faire péter en os 6
damages 4 qui arrive après d'un projet 6
c'est étonnant qu'est ce qui se passe
est un problème avec le live croît j'ai
parié caméra du dessous je sais pas ce
qui se passe je vais aller vérifier
je vais aller vérifier si ça rien moi
aussi ça vient d'eux
parce qu'honnêtement j'en sais rien
c'est sensé marche a fait un changement
là ça marche donc ça doit marcher au
quesero donc et tout va être fuite qui
est pro f 16 dont la com ont le souffle
l'on l'attendait sur tourcoing fc
tu auras fou prend 1,6 d'un pro sys même
s'attaquera ici si la dame va revenir
angers 6 il a abandonné 4 pieds sur le
droit ça se défend plus cette histoire
là donc ça fait 2-1 choix étonnant de la
part de wesley étonnant est retourné
dans cette position qui semblait qui
semblait difficile à une petite grünfeld
ça va nous changer des parties de maxime
qu'on regarde habituellement et salua
dark vador gaye bonsoir à toi j'en veux
dire bonsoir tonton j'espère que tu vas
bien
on espère tous que tu as bien d'ailleurs
donc petit tour une faille toujours les
morts qui veulent contre-attaqué le
centre un grand classique nous faut
qu'il y en ait six d'accord
on va voir comment ça continue un fou
prendra me prend kaki en verger 5e 5 ça
une certaine logique l'idée c'est que si
tu es fou prend prisé des singles par
exemple tu t'es débarrasser ton mauvais
fou donc à une certaine logique après
parti pour partie faut peut-être qu'il
continue maintenant il a retardé le rock
avec h 4 h 5 prendre prendre et rentrant
h61 ma chronique d'hier voici ma bien
prendre l'avantagé mais une cadence vont
s'accélérer je sais pas c'est un bon
guide sarma mais sur le papier c'est
c'est eh c'est juste comme levier sur
internet macha est tous assez s'en prend
tout ce truc a à coeur en plus il a un
chat on est mutti en en avatar dont le
chat forcément ça joue il est finaliste
l'an dernier il avait bien accroché n'a
qu'a donc il prend les sept îles en voie
il est sage 5 éventuelle dans cet ordre
là et salua sol ce qu'elles cachent
quatre direct il est c'est pas marrant
mais j'ai feuilleté 3 qui considère que
c'est par un problème
peut-être rock peut être joué ici parce
qu'en fait si prend des quatre youri
dame b 2 à la fin et c'est ça qui est
des codes qui est des trois quilles avec
cinq échecs et d'amener cette marie
béland marrante
après je sais pas quel point elle est
juste un bon je viens monde parce que ça
fait plein non pas ça ça pour attaquer
la terreur autour des 8 es sur pied des
quatre cavaliers premiers cavaliers f5
double échec et dames g7 matteau
prochain ça tout échange et du coup et
foulée 50 et être plus forts parce que
les fêtes il menaçait vous prend 17 et
puis on prend
bon y'a un bug avec avec les caméras des
joueurs qui partent c'est un bug avec
obs avec les serveurs on fera un jeu
pourrait les remettre après les parties
mais ça arrive dans les petits bugs
techniques comme ça donc ici et ce qui
doit jouer f3 pour tenir les pions et
préparé pour ses sets par la suite
protéger les pions et les cases prix
peut aussi être tentée par rock et prend
le 4e qui était si ce ton armée il doit
calculer conséquence de f3 est-ce que tu
auras le temps de rentrer ans et 7 de
manière forte il fait eu 5 kg 4 essais
très direct
c'est très direct et justin k efficace a
surpris tête il pensait plutôt cavaliers
t5 pour protéger de ce côté là et bien
qu'ils aient prend 1,5
il va faire tout en cinq ans j'ai des
noirs ainsi que par un pion de plus mais
vraiment sous pression autour des 8
c'est bien joué parce que sur tours d un
peut-être maintenant qu'épreuve samsara
améliora est sûre qu'elle réussisse ou
kf5 est chahuté à fou prend voilà faut
vraiment calculé un qui avait pris 1,5
faire le coup critique mais c'est
peut-être très mauvais hein
prévoit pas de réfutation direct mais ça
va être hyper intéressante ours et c'est
peut-être un petit coup de fouet et 4
encore que
sur food et 7 en fait fou 17 c'est
peut-être le coup critique un pari fou
17 il veut tout un fou prend b5 et carré
ie6 suspense assez joli
c'est joli c'est très joli
si ça passe c'est beau si ça passe
honnêtement c'est très beau après on
verra mais si ça passe c'est très beau
jeu met un petit coup d'ordi histoire de
voir les valent ils evans qui adore
l'edouard amphoux 17 soit pas marché à
cause de tout on va vérifier car il a
fait dans le temps et vous prendrez 7e
reprend 17 et camaïeu ce this way qui
est plus un même si tôt à savoir si
marché donc à 6 x 4
jordi te fais juste b5 fougue et troyes
et tours 17 comme quoi un lord il a
tellement de sang froid
lord ya tellement de sang froid que qui
te tient sa phase il paye ses katas
quand ça ça c'est logique c'est plus
humain bien sûr puisque maintenant tu
veux sur ce point j'ai la tour c 7 qui
fait rien il s'est un peu emballé au sc
alors oui à la reprise prises pour ces 4
mai et noirmont a minima l'égalité
tour des cinq donc sur cavani aussi s'il
vous prend aussi c'est sûr cavaliers f5
reprend m 5
ouais proposition de nul de la part de
mam et qui va probablement être acceptée
par wesley donc bas mais qui va
retourner dans des quatre essais 4 6 qui
a aidé à trois des cinq foulée 5 et
rejouer sa rente avec 4,4 g 4 1 pour le
moment ça lui porte grand succès essayer
de se remettre les calmes en faisant la
transition la rivière transition calme
je ne sais vraiment pas pourquoi les
cadres ont disparu
c'est vraiment sensé marchand voir ça
revient c'est un peu dommage mais ça
devrait revenir
donc il a changé son fusil d'épaulé en
caraïbe et 4 qui était pas terrible
wyclef 5.5 est évidemment fait j'ai dit
vous prend par inadvertance
maintenant il ya un tout petit en or on
va essayer de faire revenir les calmes
on va parler pour l'instant on regardera
plus tard
ah ça y est c'est revenu j'aime bien
voir les calmes perso il reste 53
minutes
salut à salim salut à l'art à roizy
wasquehaliens mais l'avis d'autres ce
matin et qui refait dam des deux avec le
même plan regardez depuis en d5 cette
fois ci le joueur américain pour tenir
la case de 4 pour empêcher aux cavaliers
de venir en aide 6 on va voir ce que ça
donne en tout cas merci merci l'art
ouaziz non mais j'ai beaucoup pêché face
j'ai pas mal bossé où cette vidéo je
vois là j'ai regardé une partie une
deuxième partie une troisième partie
d'en sélectionner ce qui me plaisait le
plus donc je suis heureux que ça fait
plus d'un mètre quatre vingt mètres il
veut peut-être faire dame f5 sur d'un f4
pour courir voilà c'est pas mal pour moi
c'est une amélioration parce que tout à
l'heure il y avait de cavaillon b4 juste
il avait perdu un temps et c'est pas un
coup qu'on jouera ici le cavalier qui
met la pression sur le pion des 4es du
qu'on attend d'eux fait retour des 8es
sur 24 peut-être de f5 et on n'aura pas
le temps de faire d'un mach 4 d'un
problème trois dames hc3 les fuites et
ya pas de match pas si vous suivez
dames 3 prépare peut-être des idées avec
camaïeu cinq dames h3 p 5 j'aime bien ce
coup sûr vous prendre je veux faire
québec après x 6 rapide et jouer
l'activité à fond
four b3
puisque faire fourrer 7
mais qui dès qu'il prend des quatre qui
est prend des 4 août prochain
et deuxième mythe et peut-être tour ses
huit cavaliers p4 ou des 5
il fait cavalier e set
ce coupon le blizzard c'est quoi l'idée
sur carieuse 5 jean raté quelque chose
je veux juste dame h3k relief cette
reprise aux six
tout bêtement devait y avoir un truc que
j'ai raté il fait d'un mètre 4 juste
regardé le premier coup dur une fois je
suis un peu curieux m5 telles que
numéros un medic et noir sont bien d'un
mètre 80 s était qu un équivalent
cavaliers f5 en soi même question est-ce
que karen yeux 4 et un coup tu as cannes
toujours envie de jaillir vers m6
c'est très compliqué
dès 5 ans c'est le bordel mais totale
parce qu'il rajoute encore ça emprise ac
le feu ses positions c'est hyper
intéressant est ce qui va prendre ses
trois prix ces trois prix c3 et en fait
il veut juste partie rectorat en b1 j'ai
l'impression et se dire qui est ce qu'il
est dur à attaquer c'est quoi le délire
ouais en tout cas c'est un beau matin
franchement franchement je kiffe la à ça
faisait longtemps qu'on n'est pas que je
vais pas commenter un joli un joli truc
après la petite dame 5 qui arrive et
tout genre fou contre on prend emprise
prises et peut-être à l'idée dames 5 qui
forcera les changes des dames et tu
rentres de partout je sais pas un c'est
le bordel surprend des 5
ce qu'on peut faire cavalier prend des
cinq s'est joué
faut ici
on voit bien j'aime bien de toute façon
le roi est mal placée et comment est ce
que les noirs ont continué 500 qu'avec
les noirs il a des pièces pas trop mal
placé mais il n'a pas d' attaque le roi
est bien cachée faudrait pas qu'ils se
prennent un carré lieu cet échec un jour
j'aime bien car et lieusaint que les
blancs sont en train de ramener leurs
pièces mais il ya toujours pas de menace
a peut-être hacker prend jce si ce qui
peut rodez bike sur pions prend
cavaliers 7 qui est procès tfou prend
aussi smat pouvoir défier pranger 6e fou
prend des cinq accueils progressistes
africains qu est ce que je vous prends
des cinq il ya dame prend et surtout eu
qu'à ta feuille adam prend peut-être kg
messieurs faites au rang des cinq à
kessoua d'échec
wen à tence à ses protégés
tendez sur pied prend c'est quoi le
délire afu prend aussi ses dames s est
évoquée mais non ça va mater et carrier
g6 a marché ou pas c'est un gros bordel
mais carey ie7 c'est hyper forte
c'est joli et il prend vous prend aussi
c'est peu plus tu peut plus défendre ma
mais qui va égaliser mais qui domine
avec les blancs ils étaient gagnants
dans les trois parties
il va falloir que wesley so règles
l'équation h4 g41 parce que dans ce
candidat mme l'asi h4 ch4 g4 la liwf qui
n'a pas pu le le conseiller couaillier
cavaliers c'est du bus laférois ici
qu'elle ces six prises prise dame là il
ya la tour qui va arriver en des
vitesses est pas tout à fait fini ça va
faire dame de plus mais ça va encore
jouer d'affaires dame de plus
et peut-être commencer par aso est
peut-être normal entre cavaliers la
sueur dame prend il ya tour des huit à
mais vous croyez que ces échecs a donc
il prend le 6e prend 2,6 pranger 6 il
n'a pas voulu prendre la dame c'est avec
les voir ensemble et bordélique de loin
près des pièces de partout c'est qu'ils
mèneront à vii
elle a sûrement camaïeu 5 quand même sur
échec
- 8
tout sur tour des huit il veut filer la
dame est joué peut-être dame g4 pour
entrer l'art et damages 2 il veut
rentrer par ici c'est bien joué ça
ces jolies parties les mecs on a reperdu
les caméras je sais pas pourquoi mais
abandon de wesley
j'essaie de refaire saute on sait pas
pourquoi donc ces quatre c'est simple
c'est une anglaise maintenant presque
avec les blancs saléen c'est surtout
avec les noirs qu'il est qui est dans le
problème par du coup je vais jouer juste
m'ouvrir le truc pour avoir les temps
sur le téléphone parce que sinon on va
pas voir les temps et s'arrêtent un
problème
c'est une anglaise c'est la variante
qu'on a vu dans la partie de maxime
contreras de rs 40 minutes comme ça j'ai
bien ouvert le truc
je crois qu'ils aient des deux ça lui
accorde tout 44 donc marquer et gagner
le grand prix à riga devant maxime 2004
ok comment est ce que les blancs
continuent c'est quand même plus
compliqué que ce qu'avaient à maxime
d'un objet 3 d'accord
sur dame prend qu on prend peut-être un
peu de jeu malgré les échanges des dames
sur le roi
ils échangent b6
gk fin il veut il va vouloir jouer pour
l'attack harel roi malgré l'absence des
dames on sso
pour des 8 d'accor et peut-être f4 g5
quelque chose comme ça fou de tatev
4-3-3 h5 écuyer tête de faye retour des
achats et g5 bêtement et j'aime bien les
blancs ouais j'ai dix aux favorites au
cra à 333 mais pas forcément parce que
ce au plus fort en blitz mais plus parce
que généralement il prend le les speech
est très au sérieux mais il faut dire
que le début de match deux mamelles avec
la le candidat mike h4 g4 ça a été assez
impressionnant
voilà j'aime bien les plans dans ses
deux versions autour des achats tête 5
d'abord feng g6
vers gaza car inégal mais si tu fais
tour dh un cac et des cas tu pourras
faire fou des empires ça va
descartes food r
ça va bien se passer bien se passer ne
t'inquiète pas les possibles pour les
cinq autres qualifiés pour les candidats
par les grands prix je mettrais bien
nepomniachi et maxime allais l'eau du
coup ça être guéri la one cartes grises
chioukhs et du coup il nous reste le
swiss qualifiait les souscripteurs j'ai
aucune idée aucune idée peut être
tellement de monde
j'avais vraiment difficile à dire
sur g5 il veut prendre du fou comme ça
ils échangent et quand et si ça rentre
il a le roi qui se cache on comprend
bien il est carré des cas dont nous
parlait mathieu à l'instant
on n'a pas les gamins c'est pas on a en
un bug assez étrange je me renseignerai
à la pause je crois que c'est que nous
qui veut bon
que l'on caché qu'ils seraient pas
contents si lloris qualifier mais je
crois que c'est plus ou moins acteur
toi tu penses qu'il va se qualifier
matthews puisse qualifier c'est quoi ton
prono
c'est quoi ton prono
en fait j'ai trahi tiens un truc
donc il ya cinq tours f1 peut-être un
jour il peut même y avoir un tour prend
des deux fous prend 1,4 à vérifier moi
les veufs pions prend le saint chrême
suroît g8 lui a peut-être à l'encaisser
le pion c'est compliqué les parties roi
c'est un c pour pouvoir faire peut-être
bouger le cavalier jamais se prendre ça
sur échec mais salue monsieur pessoa
dans comment ce match mais il a commencé
il ya une petite heure
ce qui peut jouer avec g5
avec les 5 ce serait cool ici parce que
peut-être qu'en juin et que j'ai cinq
cas l'idée c'est de faire fou g4 un jour
mais poussé si ça va venir faire fou 17
on y prend il va prendre le pion surtout
reprend fouet fils faut 8 intermédiaire
ne peut pas faire plus on prend aussi
c'est sûr fou prend 1,5 et on prend 1,7
je le demande ça vaut quoi un truc comme
ça
rappelé du foot français 3 c'est chaud
fais toi je joue elle doit faire
énormément de fautes l'un s'être
complètement de la mer ce que je raconte
mais c'est trop tactique
si on prend 1,5 veux faire quoi il veut
faire g5 et cavaliers 3 a laissé ça a
assez bien joué
puis on prend et cavalières 3 enfin vous
prendre le pouls et pris des cavaliers
trois étapes live et sur carré lisse et
6 fou ici
kaïs et 4,6 peut-être été formé mais
qu'elle fera assez fort mais qu'elle
sait capter des temps encore plus fort
d'ailleurs et à leurs ouailles réseauter
elle va ramener la tour en f2 du coup il
m'a ce tour et fit mat
/ g 4 ap fuji 6
toutefois si socke et ses premiers mots
qui viennent à l'esprit
reste que la pab et 4 maintenant puis on
prend pions prg encaissé 6 pouces et k3
je suis tous réfutent maths mais juge
que je rate un truc fou c4 maintenant et
touré fit extraordinaire c'est une
magnifique attaque de maths franchement
très très très belles parties de sauts
très sympa aronian artésien favori toi
tu penses à et krishna et coup c'est une
grosse cote de mathieu
donc
donc un changement d'ouverture gisait un
petit peu le chat
ouais c'est ce qui a changé
il a retardé le rock il a changé de
variantes il a pas réussi à la devanture
pas les caméras kerviel je vais retenter
le temps là attendez là c'est venu tête
avec leurs changements ça va revenir
voilà ça y est donc
bonsoir amamou 2002 a annoncé mieux avec
les caméras bien sûr mais bon un petit
bug donc ces trois et demi deux ennemis
jarril art il boit du thé et c'est
petite tasse en verre qu'on a souvent
réussi grâce expositions de gand guide
hamas tirait slave uta les pions des
essais qui se sont échangés les noirs
font baies 5 pouces bessette pour
essayer de de libérer leurs fous sur
laguardia gones allez les blancs on
essaye parfois toucher cette case ses 6
août à les toucher un peu les cases sur
la 6ème ranger des 6 et 6 notamment
après je suis pas sûr que maxime est le
meilleur style pour gagner en toi comme
le suisse 5 waly faye heures j'ai quand
même beaucoup de nuls
je pense que ce pays soit que soe favori
après comme toujours on peut pas
vraiment pas vraiment savoir 1
c'est difficile de se prononcer
c'est très utile de se prononcer ces
lieux deux marques et des quatre essais
ici cinq ans je vous disais cette casse
et si ce qui est visé
c'est en selle sur le pro de manu ray
mais vous êtes dur avec sow quand même
c'est vrai qu'il fait beaucoup de news
est dur vous êtes dur avec wesley n'est
pas forcément complètement tort mais bon
il fait ce qui peut le petit wesley il
avait un style plus offensif lorsqu'il
était jeune et puis il s'est mis à jouer
un peu moins un peu moins offensif par
la suite
bon c'est comme ça et vous êtes dur très
dur
extrêmement dur
ce qui nous manque un annuler à tort
mais non il y aura 10 rio au candidat je
sais pas si ça peut donner mais guérit
qu'il y avait bien joué il ya quatre ans
candidat sacrifice attend n'y a pas au
jeu suit penser qu'ils avaient ce el
fahm aux autres trucs mais y avoue un
set ça j'ai eu planté ce truc là j'ai eu
planté ce truc là et sa déjà très bien
marché prend 5 points 5 et 17 bien fou
aux 7
ce que met un quart ayant ses six ans
sur la question est ce qu'un coup comme
ça peut être intéressant tu menaces la
civière
je vais peut-être faire un truc comme ça
et s'il fait face et pour voir ce jour
ni d après ce que je vous montre ça pas
forcément des douanes variante 1 mais
pour essayer de près mais il a joué
y'avait tour c'est cette hausse y
mettons c'est ça tu avais fou prend ses
7 quel pourcentage de l'unc arsène
conserver son titre
70 75 manu s'est inquiété pour le titre
cette année ou pas selon toi amateurs de
l'inquiéter vu que son titre n'est pas
remis en jeu cette année
donc si quelqu'un réussi à l'inquiéter
c'est qu'il est très fort
mais à moins d'un problème de santé
gravissime taille s'est pas enfermé le
canal 1 il veut tout reprend des cinq
puis on prend qui est progressiste qui
est prend des 5
non il n'est juste pas vu en fait ça
soit n'y a rien d'autre non
il ya eu 4 aussi
qui a dû résister entre les deux
j'en prends
alors ici à prendre un f3 prendre ici ce
front russe il fait des six essais tour
c'est cette annonce a c'est sûr il va
jouer au sein qui va enfermer le fou
faut vite réagir pour rester pour obame
et la tournée 3,5 tour pro f 3 ar wives
en fait ce qui se passe que cinq tours f
3.736 mais tu veut peut-être joué g4
aussi tour des cafés f5
bonjour a choisi la ham est sur eux cinq
points des trois rois et 7,6 à fou
contre cinq il ya un problème
double clouage c'est chaud
cette rangée 6
ted h4
par pourtour c3 et il se laisse enfermer
le fou il peut le faire revivre avec f3
foule f2
il peut le faire revenir à 4-3 foued
ils ont fait mieux pourquoi pas mais ça
restait compliquée donc c'est ouais
c'est maintenant qu'ils allaient blanc
et qui a toujours un point d'avancé ça
peut encore de 100 écaillage quatre
opérateurs 3g si dame b 3 dames ses sept
fous des deux fous des 6 ou kebede cette
fosse est encore autre chose tour c'est
un truc peut faire cavalier e 4 kg si ce
qui est des deux tu tapes ici qu'est le
quatre pions prend fou prend 1,4 g iii
intéressant après tu peux prendre et
faire car et le cateau prochain ce que
la dame soit là ou là tu la touche en d2
avec un maillot 4 je pense nantes en
championnat lors des puisque s'ajuste à
m'intéresse personnellement quatre
l'ordi propose qui est proche qui prend
1,4 fou 3 h 4 fait revenir au caire
bon il g3 mc est le roi des deux et puis
on prend juste à la fin aux biches à je
préfère aller blanc ses positions là tu
as quand même le centre et la paire de
fou même si sa structure de pions et un
peu bizarre c'est fou h5 alors une
menace g5 et fou prend f3 donc il a
protégé
il reste 21 une minute donc
théoriquement il reste sept parties et
peut-être deux autres encore il ya
encore le temps de de travailler
est-ce que car à eux deux qui avait les
f4 et une idée qu'un léger deux
cavaliers f4 d'être plus fort
on va voir
pas évident j'ai 4 et 6 et g5 wey kaw 8
f4 probablement il va verrouiller les
cases noires il prendra le fou de cases
blanches après mais f k tu laisses
fouache 5 aces qui veut faire fois je
sens coupat j'en sais rien
compliqué très compliqué vraiment est ce
que y'a peintres comme ça je m'emballe
peut-être je touche ici j'aurais m touré
vii qu'à rallier la dame ici
ouais y'a rien qu'il a pris prix et
foods 2 bon ok ces sacs
d5 est peut-être une option
4 alors sur sion prend c'est quelle
découverte
ouais c'est joli surplombant chaud y ait
des cinq dates des 8 kg et prend dame
prend et fourbe et 4 mai salle elle est
pénible encore que jouable
j'aurais peut-être quelque chose hein en
plus d'allemands de choses en prise à
gauche à droite tour ses huit car il a
rien de plus normal
fou 3 normal aussi protège
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment hyper
complexe en les mecs c'est vraiment des
parties où il garde beaucoup de pièces
émises en voit de partout mais là les
plans semblent quand même prendre un peu
le dessus
donc la position la paire de foudre une
position qui s'ouvre ça reste très
concret donc la sueur fou prend ses cinq
as jamais découverte puisqu'il a repris
sur échec
dame b 4 ans ait encore la taille tu va
se mettre dans le viseur mais hassa dans
le viseur de saya luthier ouvert là il
ya des possibilités tactiques de tous
les côtés mais la question de jours pour
sûr qu'est prend 1,4 si vous quoi il
veut travailler prendre cavaliers prend
pour prendre fou prend et on prend ici
j'imagine à certains lots qui est
nouveau
c'est très très chauvin
c'est vraiment vraiment la folie pays
sur la colonnade enfin ça va prendre
quand même un deux trois quatre coups au
mieux et il sent difficile avant le
temps de le faire ça lui a gardé pas
peur comme ça il y avoir eu le droit à l
appel de la part du président nous
l'avons pas qu'ils nous parlent d'avoir
un seul s'enchaînent bitstream sa écoles
et les alertes du coup elles sont un
sourire une hauts-de-seine tout cas
merci si quelqu'un à seube élan qui rend
dans le truc on compte on parlait à
l'instant qu'ils éprouvent quatre
épreuves quatre avec un échange massif
qui va arriver
celle-là jésus-christ y apprend qu'il
prend ses entreprend 600 prend les
quatre premiers sets
et qu'est-ce qui a vu à feinter sens que
ça semblait donc bien pour les blancs ça
allait me faire pousser 5 à la fin j'ai
tour c1
ouais il veut empêcher je vais juste
regarder avec l'ordi ce que je comprends
pas le problème fondamental de tout
reprend bessette bond à 5 et j'ai trouvé
cette a5 et savoir en fait pour tout le
monde et donc les nas contre avec un
pion plus mais la tour est bien placé et
à la paire de fou qui contrôlent
beaucoup de cases apprend que juste
partie des 2 éventuellement prises
reprendre de la tour fouet f3 il peut
faire qu'il y avait deux qui est des
trois maintenant
hockey hebdo keyaerts trois échecs et
prend un f4 mais bon tellement difficile
à juger ce truc là à mes points forts
c'est que tu va menacer un matin un
moment donné genre là tu me l'as tour et
formate ce qui est pénible effet qu'à
aider si ce qu'on met 7 à 5
ils ont encaissé ça au prochain une
cavale et qui va pouvoir rejaillir
cavalli c4 c'est dur à juger
ouais alors maintenant savent surtout
reprend des six tours prend tour à 6
tours b katura 5tourcoing f4
ça peut être chiant à jouer quoique
peut-être le retour à éviter chèque pour
enfermer il préfère regarder le fou
j'aurais pas les laisser ce cavalier
envie non pas les pièces bouger quand on
réalise alors des fois je mets les
flèches parce que ça peut avancer quoi
t4a mais c'est pas un réseau de match
on va les flèches n'est pas une pièce
mais il voit les fesses quand je mets
les flèches en fait on va les pieds
quand je les pièces bouger mais si tu as
les fesses tu peux les faire bouger dans
ta tête
c'est pour pouvoir garder les pièces du
direct qui bouge que je fais que les
flèches mais ça suit un cd ventes de 3,4
au maximum
ah c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait et ce
aux îles menacées 2 et hymne à jay 6 et
quand il va prendre j'ai ici si menacera
match c'est quoi le délire sur vous
prendrez 6 il monte le roi mais attends
c'est pas les blancs qui sont mieux
maintenant toi cet échec mais clairement
et tours 7
or ces salles à temps il peut encore
sauver sa avec trois rois julien
cavalière 3 huawei fin qu'un voyage de
wen f1 kf3 roi des huns tour des deux
rois c'est un tour des huit sur quoi si
on prend g5 et pranger 5e tour et 8
échecs et cavaliers qui va revenir ans
et 4 ans il fait pour eux quatre ils
échangent il va mettre l'option g6 nom
étonnant qu'il ait pas kaka 1-6
intermédiaire il ya il le fait
maintenant et tout au cas où le roi qui
est bloqué en le roi qui est bloquée et
il est tombé mais c'était hyper chaud y
avait encore tour g3 et je pense que
c'était nul
extraordinaire
ça frise les pièces bouge pas on ne pas
friser pour moi mais bon
le bric d'affichage sais pas d'où il
vient ce bug d'affichage
on va essayer de faire revenir les
joueurs j'ai aucune idée d'où ça vient
enfin ça va bien de l'avoir un problème
sur un serveur quelque part sur une
connexion ou sur un truc
je ne veux pas savoir dans ce sens hier
donc c'est parti on a raté les caprices
et ses variantes du grand vide à
m'accepter ouest et qui a pris deux
points d'avance dans une super partie
salut à 76 au lit salut à gaz maire
salua tim k 1 fry c'est un championnat
officiel bah ouais en quelque sorte ça
alors de championnat du monde officieux
de 2 litres sur internet pour en gros en
tout cas ce sont des belles parties
qu'on voit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça joue vraiment ça joue
vraiment bien
donc il reste apparemment 9 minutes et
quelques il reste 1 minute et quelques
de cette cadence
j'espère voir autrui le le visage des
joueurs ça devrait revenir donc ça
ressemble à quoi s'instruire de pions
dès lors deux françaises où le pion au
cices a été remplacé par le fou pas
qu'il prendrait quatre skis à prendre le
5e ça m'est arrivé quand même un tout
comme d'am dam à 5 peut-être
c'est comme un s'effrayant mais aurait
créé 6,2 n'a pas pris
souffert qu'il prend aux six pions
prendre à mach 5 j 6 damage six
cavaliers 5-fu g5 à nos yeux rivés n'dam
g7 qui va arriver rs devrait il fait et
b3 à il va attaquer ici est menacé ça
mais c'est beaucoup plus fort
l'élu a gagné le pion des 5
il a l'air pas mal de manet il a l'air
pas mal
il a l'air pas mal ce qui est con des
cinq ses forces avant 5 heures il ya eu
six échecs prendre cinq là il n'y a rien
qui marche
c'est fou tu as même un innocent d'alger
3 si tu prends des saints comprend 1,5
sur échec et sur roc fait j'avais cette
idée là où j'ai cinq équidés sur m6
aucun problème si c'est pouvoir te taper
à la nar an prochain mais il veut
peut-être contre taper aides de l'anah
qui table sur les chaînes qui a pas de
souci ben j'ai 3 a une belle gueule je
faire plus ou moins fous j'ai cinq sur
tout ce qui bouge en fait est sûre
qu'elle réussisse pareil alors
évidemment il peut en cacher la dame est
tu pour apprendre ici et ça va peut-être
pour les noirs jordan des huit ici
j'aurais tellement pas cher de la peau
des noirs mais qui au pire tu prends tu
fais m3 et tuent les enquêtes p 6
madame g iii damas cinq à ces mêmes
idées fait refouler 5
non mais c'est très difficile à mai sur
fou g5 qui veut faire quoi alors est ce
que vraiment en fait il veut il
attaquait f2 c'était ça le problème sur
d'alger 3 c'était cavalier fait quatre
ans qu'il a essayé peut-être qui est pro
b 6 h 3 et d'un projet 7
c'est hyper intéressant une nouvelle
fois comme parti
il ya des coûts intermédiaires possible
de partout mais wesley qui est dans le
dur
et dans le dur voir ce que ça donne mais
il est vraiment grand
dans la difficulté donc il a prié f2 roi
chain dame des sept mois il accepte il
accepte car aliev six échecs
il reprend du cavale comme l'un des
meilleurs matchs 5
francis mais il garde toujours quand
même deux menaces ils menacent ici ce
qui peut faire dame c6 fou j'ai sept
tours g8 dame prend 1,7 à il a pas grand
roque parce que la tour couvre damas
quatre sur fou j'ai sept il veut quoi
donc g8 dame prend je vois pas le
problème
ils contrôlent h dont il contrôle déjà
jusqu'à mais il veut d'un match 4 pour
revenir courir f6 au cas où genre damage
siffler d'arachide arrache 4 qui est des
cas de bien jouer bloque la connexion ça
devrait passer là
ce que tour des huit et un coup l'idée
c'est de jouer sur 7 sur ce truc là
c'est vraiment des belles parties 1
franchement o'keefe un des trois qui ça
c'est logique pour couper la connexion
un emploi est ce qu'on peut dire ce
qu'on veut prendre prendre et prendre là
bas pour jouer sur le mode du couloir a
levé veut tout semblant reprendre
ce qui va faire bamba k
mais maintenant il ya plus les problèmes
de clouage donc le cavalier va pouvoir
bouger
alfredo lâchant que là ça fait quarante
fois qu'on me demande j'ai déjà expliqué
qu'ils avaient un blog aujourd'hui on a
toujours les caméras aujourd'hui pour
une raison x ou y la manière dont on
récupère les flux à chaque fois bug
c'est pas pourquoi après
c'est pas non plus la fin du monde il
n'y a pas d'âme j'ai c'est quand même
pas empêché le plus important sur un
scream déchets qui se trouve ça devrait
marcher mais ça marche pas on sait pas
pourquoi la défense de dessous est juste
incroyable dans désolé c'est jusqu'à 40
personnes qui demandent depuis tout à
l'heure c'est un peu relou ok faut f6 si
on fait tout reprend tour prend et on
peux pas alors haye me défends la et sur
dame ces six tours d1 dames c'est un
tour des huit tours des huit tours sert
à aller ce qui va tomber
aweys est bien joué quel parti encore
kate partie incroyable
quelle partie incroyable retrouver les
caméras on va les reperdre jeux pas trop
ce qui se passe avec donc comme ça en
allaitant ouais ça a dû finir à une
seconde près
alors du coup c'était un genre je vais
jouer une estonienne contre des 4es du
court on sait où un ou une brune fine on
se retrouve avec un pib de 4 avec une
position assez égal ou quoi c'est qui
mène 5 4
donc
position assez égale est ce que les
joueurs vont la jouer à fond pas en tout
cas où est ce l'équipe qui réalise un
gros match en défense
dames et trois échecs loup qui va
revenir en h 4 way he gave un petit
quelque chose pour les blancs un pas
énorme assez bauza sur pions prend il
veut toujours là et surtout 27 pour
défendre 6 vous prend des cats et puis
on prend 1,7 sur échec s'il vous plaît à
ya un bon niveau de jeu 1 il ya des
badges ou de tactique dans ce dans ce
match
ouais ça fait plaisir ça joue mieux
qu'hier c'est un match plus plus
agréable à suivre
ah ouais c ay krief 7 encore c'était le
coup de trop il avait vu probablement
roi je suis cavaniol 5
parce qu'il aurait peut-être pu rentrer
dans un truc de ce type la reprise prise
prise prise prise prisé tour d un quitus
comme ça qui est qu un avantage blanc je
pense à cause de ce pion encore que les
bons rails 3 kg 7 mois et tourner autour
de cette parade excusez moi je raconte
n'importe quoi
sow qui a très bien joué il a vu le tour
des 1 tour 7 parle autant pour moi parce
que sur qui on prend g5 sont ceux qui te
fier de vous bouger le fou mais y'aura
carrier pranger 5e à prendre f7 en force
des tours 17 en 1er année en ce qui est
vraiment bon
ouais mal mais qui veut jouer pour du
dmp un discours resté peut pas juste
faire flouer 3 il commence par tour des
5 mhz et d'un béret cheikh tour d un
adam f 5 au pire adalbert il veut
toujours 20 qu'est ce qu'ils voient vite
or mais qu'est ce qu'ils voient vite
tour des cinq dames b1 tourer non c'est
monstrueux et donc sur d'american juste
à je crois le flou genre à taper sa mère
x ou y
on fait juste tours fc twente america
tour 7 pions prends-toi fsa était rideau
un tournoi à vii en bref ça t'apprend
les sept matches mais c'est magnifique 1
à ces magnifiques
elle était vraiment by salariat bravant
des belles parties les mecs seule elle
était vraiment jolie dame b entourant
franchement c'est beau parce que jean tu
fais tourner 50 il vient et tu ramènes
le tour franchement ces festivals
franchement ces festivals ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir voilà on va
partir pour une pause on a reperdu
l'image je sais vraiment pas quoi faire
j'espère qu'elle va revenir je voulais
la petite musique et en espérant que ça
revienne je vais essayer de régler le
problème a chuté mec
[Musique]
bon les mecs vraiment un problème avec
avec les grands
mais on sait pas d'où ça vient je suis
en train d'écrire et tout ça mais j'ai
une bonne nouvelle ce sera face qui
commentera vendredi samedi et dimanche
le le comment s'appelle le les quarts de
finale du championnat du monde de fisher
en sommes donc c'est un bel événement ce
sera cool donc ce sera vendredi samedi
et dimanche à partir de 16 heures ce
sera cool donc il y aura un nouveau de
nouvelles choses à voir
est elle pas être chez moi
et vendredi soir je serai sûrement
l'aréna parce que c'est du 960 et on m'a
dit que le problème était sur absolument
tous les live internationaux donc donc
donc voilà on peut ainsi faire c'est
comme ça c'est la vie il ya ces
problèmes de caméra
le seul truc c'est que c'est que
c'est que ça pose pas non plus pour moi
pour avoir le temps qui reste est tout
donc je vais retourner je vais je vais
repartir j'ai refermé la porte en fait
j'étais juste venu vous dire ça et je
vais je vais me garder
c'est de garder ces choses tu en train
de regarder live en même temps un
problème avec tout le monde
on va essayer d'envoyer du lourd a on va
essayer envoyer du lourd
ok j'ai écrit encore un petit truc comme
ça si on est censé à être encore en
pause
c'est juste que je suis revenu parce que
rien à faire
donc
dans le nom donc
on va continuer à envoyer le match va
être sympa fait peut-être mettre un
score à la rigueur et le score on va
l'avoir ici mais je vais remettre le
score peut-être quelque part de côté je
sais pas je vais voir si ça revient
vraiment pas
si vous êtes nouveau sur la chaîne
n'hésitez pas à paulo le match va
bientôt reprendre
on peux te lâcher les styles en live je
suis pas ça veut dire elle fait dans la
chante là
donc
ça devrait reprendre je suis gérant le
premier devoir regarder sur le live pour
avoir des infos parce que du coup j'ai
vraiment mis à part sur le téléphone
je peux pas avoir les infos du vrai live
ça va reprendre et nous disent quoi
ouais c'est ça reste équilibré en après
d'après larigot rythme c'est ce qu'avait
prévu la go rythme de points d'écart on
va voir
ok voir on va lancer
on va lancer
on va voir ce que ça donne
je reçois bien les coudes et non à ce
niveau tout comme nike ou de nouvelles
tours ouais mais bon quand tu es perdu
tu es perdu un nombre n hésitez pas
folle au mas de faux l'eau de partout et
on va repartir dans quelques instants
ces belles belles compétitions 1
alors attendez j'entends des coups
pourquoi pourquoi je ne vois pas à
l'écran ça y est c'est parti
[Musique]
donc on va voir peut-être le droit à une
ragots zine après des cinq dans ces cinq
dix mesures de la part de wesley ouest
et sow qui va avoir une bonne partie
avec les noirs il va plus se prendre les
h4 g4 qui s'est pris tout le long
peut-être qu'il prend des salaires
pendant ces 3 français 3 du fou qui on
prend cinq questions à fabriquer b3
foule si ce nom vous aussi avez ses
cadres et ses 600 premiers c'était
débile c'est normal de faire quelques
600 premiers qui est pays si sir vise la
casse ces quatre faux droits télés c4 ou
pas cette fois f5
je sais pas pour vous prendre son temps
à réfléchir la caisse et quatre pouces
et 5 non tours 8
éventuellement ces fous des 5 mai fu ou
six façons touré sékou donc qu'est-ce
qui me faire d'autres cavaliers cet adam
prend des huîtres ou prendre cette tour
des huit food et 5
faut aussi ça a l'air d'être solide
dams et de faire tourner un et fous des
cinq peut-être plus tard autour des 1 et
quelque chose il ya des dames 4 aussi
qui peut rodez aller retour des 1 mais
ils n'arrivent pas à f4
c'est pas mal ça ils envoient hammam et
puis on prend efficace il va quoi il va
prendre de la tour est doublé rapidos
bonjour ai jamais joué ça quand même un
ticket qu'il y en a cinq qui va bien
tenir pas mal de choses des cavs a lieu
trois équipes ça ça parait vraiment
bizarre ce f4 pas ce que vous en pensez
dans le chat fou et 6
j'aurais pas j'aurais pas jouer ça
je n'aurais pas joué ça honnêtement
alors qu'à ses saints qu'au prochain
c'est quand même vrai faux aussi ce
qu'est celle c'est intéressant mon père
m car ayant 1 5 ha et s'il faut bien on
sait 4,7 cavaliers qui sera attaché mais
peut-être pour vous ces quatre baies 5
cavaliers j'ai ici c'est ce qui prend
aussi ses intermédiaires il touche par
la dame tout 1 80 m en lasse et c'est
que des coups que je serais incapable de
jouer en fait la tour en 1 4 prêtait pas
d'autres cases mais dans l'idée
d'envoyer la tour en 1 4 pour moi ça
c'est spatial nous retrouver avec une
tour ici mais ma foi pourquoi pas il ya
fait retour 800 prendre option le nom
ils échangent autour des 6 me soit assez
bien joué et la tour en a quatre et
complètement perdus non il va mettre la
dame en 17 et il va menacer de rentrer
ou en des huit d'ailleurs en des huit
peut-être d'ailleurs ou 1,17 faut
prendre ces six il y aura toujours tour
à tour la est prise sur échec et sa tour
à 4 allait super mal placé non mais
c'est et spatial non tu parce qu'on
avait pensé mais ça moi ça a paru assez
spatiale comme vous
alors est ce qu'il va faire des deux
tours d un tour des deux tours d2 direct
da me 4,6 il reste assez solide comme
avec les blancs les noirs qui
réussissent pas à toucher
ouais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
belle partie les amis niveaux indus f53
cette f4 ça va envoyer ce à partir là
les app stores etc on y va on envoie
dames c'est qu'à 3 h 7 à 6 tours est
insuffisant selon augmenté les chances
des dames à il veut taper 2 2 à la fin
c'est marrant ça joue agressif agressif
et surtout effroi cavagnoud 5-fu prend
on prend 2,3 g 1
ouais c'est chaud ça reste chaud il faut
répliquer sur angers 6 pour pouvoir
venir
il prend il prend un relief 5 et d 3 qui
va arriver au prochain mais à vous prend
à six cavaliers trois échecs croyais fin
tour à 500 quand autre chose il cloue le
icool cavaliers basse et c'est
passionnant comme partie est maintenant
peut-être fou prend 1,6 à l'orangé
lacérant passionnant ça envoie de
partout à tomber deux qui attaquent le
fou c'est bien joué ça le petit chaque
hélas tout raciste qui menace le
cavalier il va sûrement supprimer en
cavalier que kelly des deux sur wuala y
aura quelqu'un qui est pro am 2
ça peut être
il va essayer de faire nul wesley mais
attend et et détroit maintenant roi b1
tourbe et de roi les cavaliers des deux
allait y aura tombé 6 à la fin il ya
tomber 600 corps ou à 4 il n'y a pas de
match d'échecs échec trois là il ya
cavaliers b en maths mais le roi se
cache et il n'y a pas mieux que nulle
olala c'est pas assez incroyable comme
partie incroyable incroyable les mecs
extraordinaires les fous qui ont défendu
les cavaliers qui ont attaqué c'était
vraiment vraiment vraiment une belle
partie nam et qui aurait peut-être dû en
supprimant cavaliers français qui les
fait reprend ses quatre pour se
débarrasser d'un des deux mais voilà il
n'a pas fait
et du coup il a pas il n'a pas pu il n'a
pas pu l'emporter
alors j'essaye à chaque fois de faire le
petit le petit changement pour trouver
les caméras cruellement fait le petit
changement de scène il reste combien de
temps il reste 53 minutes voient les
petits changements de scène qui fait
réapparaître les caméras je ferai de
temps en temps ce petit changement de
scène censée récupérer la part placard
pour une paire d'heures je crois que les
partis qui sont pas voir et c'est
reparti donc là il reste cinquante et
une minutes cassé c'est un beau match
les mecs qu'on est en train de suivre ça
fait plaisir ça fait même très plaisir
madame b 3 peut-être pas perdre et 4
aussi
dekel ça retombe un truc théorique et
fillon prendra me paie 3 et tous ses
mythes le retour a été cadré ça existe
vraiment pas terrible pour pour les
noirs ça ressemble à une variante des
chances de la slave ou les blancs
auraient gagné quelque temps après c'est
dans le style de wesley so 1 donc la
tour qui arrive en c1
enfin du cavaliere quatre cavaliers c5
peut-être car lieux saints est bon mais
c'est dur à jouer pour les noirs
desseins que vous restiez carrier blanc
donc fait wilma mais se retrouve à jouer
il s'est fait avoir par leurs deux coups
ça arrive a annoncé dans ces matches ont
de se faire avoir par l'ordre mais là du
coup les pièces de mâts mais qui sont un
peu un peu plus regroupé peut plus
reprendre vie y est ça va ça va tout à
fait encore face et pas perdu mais
évidemment les noirs qui ont ce petit
problème d'espacé avec le pion aux cinq
bien placé mais ce qui a fait retour ce1
protéger son pion qu'à valider un pour
attaquer le feu au passage tour f3
peut-être en otage le pion et prépare
une montée de la tour toile frein sympa
il ya peut-être des d4 après trois des
quatre caricatures prend 2,3 c'est
difficile
on va voir ce que ça donne je resterai
le score c6 et demi quatre et demi enfin
voir de wesley il a fait cas était alors
qu'ils empêchent des quatre puits qui
l'attaquent ici il aura le temps de
faire h 3o prochain il a pris son temps
- c'est enfin je crois qu'avec les
injustices forcé fait g4 quand même le
cake il peut repartir en f2 ou c3
d'abord pourquoi pas de toute façon si
lecavalier bien là il y aura des écarts
imagine cf2 quand même inquiets de vrais
acquis peut pas arriver encore scassa
emprise qui fait naviguer latour mamie
qui s'en est bien sorti un mec une
partie vraiment a vraiment intéressante
les deux hommes qui se rendent coup pour
coup
on va voir tour 2 et 4
f5 par la suite
j'ai quatre ouvrages de f cfa au g4 3 2
4 aussi dans le cas tu auras des quatre
ce que tu fais chier capta tout peut
bien rangée de d'ailleurs et envoyait f5
et quelque chose comme ça
prise mais je pensais que vous
l'intéressé food et 4 way
alors il veut jouer en fait complètement
autrement il veut jouer pour la
structure de plus avec le quart eli qui
va dominer le fou mais c'est rennes qui
est pas le bug d'affichage sur la chaîne
chaise comme puisqu'on met ses allées le
bug d'affichage sur toutes les autres
chaînes qui essaye de récupérer le flux
de chess comme pour avoir les bonnes
images
il n'y a pas cinq intermédiaire est-ce
que tu prends ici puisque dame cécilia
cara lieu cet objet de faire d'amd 8 et
apsys mascara ie7 j'étais en train de le
vent aux îliens d'alger 5 ou là là là là
où est cela qui fait mal bien jouer mal
et qui résistent qui avait lieu cette en
premier un ebook lyon prend est d'alger
cinq échecs c'est violent l'aspect en
train de faire ou st so est il à la tour
ans et 8 qui emprise il va faire dame g5
à mon avis il a calculé jusqu'au mas
tourcoing fc 3 points accepte la nef 6-3
utah dans ce soir là et on voit ici d'un
3ème set bien jouer wesley ouest et qui
prend le large + 3 on va se remettre le
petit ça marche et quand on a changé
d'image et qu'on est
on est resté et qu'on est resté un petit
peu sur cet écran alors j'ai compris
comment éviter un peu le bug qui a eu à
3h 6 et après 4,5 et f3 qui est saisie
ce fou c4 donc qu'il veut jouer une
italienne avec à 3h 6 introduit c'est
intéressant
mais cette variante là pourquoi est ce
que tu en as she serait mal placé
charles sens que ça va tout à fait pour
les sauts mais la mecque est en train
d'un petit peu craqué un mais wesley qui
a été vraiment vraiment redoutable en
défense tel le roseau
il a plié mais il n'a jamais rompu il
faut que m'avait s'accroche faut pas
lâcher ma mais il faut pas lâcher
si tu lâche c'est cuit c'est la même ces
cui cui
il nous faut absolument rien lâcher
ouais c'est qui va pas faiblir c'est un
genre de nadal 1 il ne faiblit pas il
reste il reste toujours au même niveau
de de détermination et ils ne lâchent
absolument rien j'écarte alors fou j'ai
ici cette reprise prise détroit sef 5 et
sur foot france et 6
attend il a raté ça c'est pas possible
viager vous pranger 4 x 4 le retour et
dames f6 il l'a pas ratée c'était hyper
fort non il a pris comme ça alors il a
raté ce que leur disais que c'était
carrément gagnant pour les noirs
quasiment mais du coup il a raté et puis
allez sûrement pas vu ça a été
incroyable de voir ça donc là il ya quoi
matériellement il ya un pion de moins
pour les noirs et une structure pourri
pour les noirs je pense que h 5 h 3
c'est moins grave que c7 c6
en effet nab et 8 d'accor et la tête
l'idée de faire f 4 tours b 5 twh 5
ouais c'est ça c'est très bien joué
tombé 5 tout reproche t-on retour g5 est
ici un jour de faire de match 5e tour h5
ouais il a raté ma destinée je crois je
pense pas qu'il l'ait laissé jouer ça
parce que maintenant tout rejet cinq
dames f53 5 c ça me semble pénible il
peut lire des histoires où tu as acquis
vient l'aca qui vient la talent rend à
jouer toile et tourcoing 3 dames fera je
croyais trois échecs
je pense que c'est très pénible si le
roi parents et femmes cette même dame f7
d'ailleurs pour viser ccaf c'est my
fellow y met le plan à exécution
il va faire tout reproche cinq noms
puisque sur un pied qu'à turin toujours
3e 3 échecs tour g4 d'accord
oui bon c'est ce qu'il pouvait faire de
mieux un mais plus un kappa emprise
haitham des 5 et c'est sympa à ça parce
que sur dame prend qu on prend il se
remet bien la structure et bloque les
pions adverse sur noir mais c'est sur
ces coups là en fait qu'ils sont si
forts tu vois un d'amd 5 c'est pas et en
plus y'a paroisse g2 parce qu'avec trois
échecs en soit c'est pas si dur à
trouver
mais le truc c'est qu'il les trouve à
chaque fois c'est ça qui est dur
un simple coup c'est pas dur maintenant
moi j'ai deux
moi je crois peut-être mais dans le
dessin en fait c'est une joue un bruce
poil de ce que tu as à jouer avant trois
sets maintenant 3 6 3 f 5 qui va monter
ou touré 8 aussi est candidat il y
aurait tout rien ne devrait peut-être
tours 8
donc princes 4 d'abord et toute façon la
tour était mal placé non mais c'est
pourquoi ces petits coups et c'est pas
spécialement des coûts de revient pour
la peine de mort je regarde je regarde
pas ce match avec leur vie du tout là
c'est un match vraiment passionnant donc
je suis vraiment à fond dedans saluer et
l'eau des lacs
quand les matches sont vraiment beau ça
donne vraiment pas envie d'allumer la
bécane c'est parfois des matches qui
sont un peu plus ennuyeux j'ai du mal
être être plus à fond dedans mais là
quand ça joue vraiment bien et que ça
des belles partitas vraiment envie d'y
vivre le match à fond ça y est 24 la loi
tu vas venir en aide 5 et tours j'ai dit
on chez ou la scéne gafsa temps on s'est
passé quoi sur ton prend à chaque échec
je pense qu'ils ont raté tous les deux
dans mes limites tour à 800 je n'ai pas
eu peur il va vouloir échanger les tours
mais qui veut pas
il peut progresser avec les noirs ne
veut pas non plus à aimer tour g6
maintenant s'ils m'avaient tant de tours
huit tours à huit tours prend ainsi s'il
va se faire contrer wesley qui tente
finalement a surtout profité à tour h61
au tour 3 rien à faire ça va faire nul
c'est chose faite allons essayer de se
remettre les caméras pour ça
la seule technique pour la fourrure way
attendre deux minutes voilà on a trouvé
la technique pour pour récupérer les
caméras alors là est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des france 3 des français trois dames
c'est 7 4 et après à chécy s'il veut
encore différemment ça c'est ça ça
suivait la partie mvl radjabov faraj
rahho fnpl le score est de et de 8,5 en
faveur de west ces trois points d'écart
donc c'est pas encore fait 6 il m'a même
amenée il a par exemple la première
partie du match il était gagnant il a
perdu c'est ouais c'est qu'il ya un tout
petit peu celui dominé séverine 10 en
temps réel et ouais c'est en direct ça
joue bien ça joue vraiment bien c'est
vraiment un match de grande qualité
conçu ensemble ce soir peut-être un b3
c'est bien joué c'est bien joué c'est
bien joué
ouah camp rock composé de la part de
wesley d'être un fou qu'il y en a eu
deux et surtout eu six dames à 3 quelque
chose comme ça dams et 2 d'ailleurs et
surtout prend 1 2 p 3 pour l'enfermer un
fou island et j'ai envie de dire c'est
youri g4 je pense au prochain
quoique tous vraiment avec g4 attention
g4 fou prend à deux baies 3 à 4 tab 3 2
prises b3 il ya ces trois qui tombent
aussi fait 1,5
il ferme la diagonale du fou prendre ce
pion c'est un peu se fourvoyer
ok tu as eu 4 ou des trois ça peut-être
arriver ça va peut-être arriver il va
falloir être méfiant côté azéri
je pense à daric alger carthage 5-fu
détroit j'ai pas dit exactement le plan
en entier désolé mais car les dessins
que c'est dangereux c'est bien jouer il
me lasse le fou ou 3 il ya au sein qui
peut rester un peu en prise à rêver non
mais j'aime bien j'aime bien là mais en
fait les blancs qui n'ont pas le temps
d'organiser le truc c'est trop long il
faudrait un deux trois quatre coups et
l'attaquent noir et noir créé des
menaces quasiment à tous les coups c'est
long il ya des fous f5 qui rôde aussi
peut-être à ces cas tu auras qui décale
autour des 8 j'aime bien mais qui se
replacent h5 donc ils commencent à
vouloir affaiblir les cases blanches
mais fouet f5
du coup il y avait plus fous des trois
parce qu'il y avait un truc avec a et b
4e rang des trois dames à 4 alors il
veut g4 maintenant et revenir peut-être
vers 4 c'est bien joué de rigueur car l
idée qu un excellent coup sûr pions
qu'on comprend l'esprit jesse ses gaffes
ou seydoux qui traîne il ya poussé de
aussi qui menace il est très mal passée
wesley en sueur un ouais c'est en grosse
sueur
réussite de l'accord dams et 6 tan tan
tan tan tan tan tan quoi pas fous ces
deux âges et compris parce que sur des
français 6 qui prend de matt aut c'est
joli os et jolie les mecs donc b3 et
dames 4 pour aller faire dan behrman aux
extraordinaires d'accès 6o le cavaly
prend à de maths a le calibre à de maths
qui menaçait
assez joli très très très joli à attaque
côté à côté azéri
il a fait le boulot le joueur azéri
magnifique magnifique jeu de la part de
de mam et qui recommence par a3
écouteurs il n'était pas très bien dans
la partie précédente mais très très
belle attaque tout cas on voit déposés
chaque ce soir et c'est à souligner
parce qu'on dit souvent wesley so machin
est tous en tout cas ce soir
ce qu'on est en train de vivre ensemble
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment des baux
échec
on peut s'en réjouir mais qu'avec son à
trois jours un truc un peu hybride mais
il est encore dans le match et les
cadeaux point ma mais les joueurs qui se
rendent coup pour coup et qui sait
donner réalisa un gros match en speech
elsa il faut il faut souligner une belle
performance du joueur azéri ça se
souligne c'est vrai qu'on avait un peu
on avait quelques doutes sur sur son
implication émotionnelle mental et son
envie de jouer la compétition et face au
finaliste de l'an dernier wesley so il
offre un combat au niveau 1 pour le
moment avec finalement il est mené de
deux points mais sur sur ouais il ya eu
une ou deux parties qui ont patron des
dents sont sans salaire après c'est tout
haut c'est tout au mérite cci mérite
revient à wesley so aussi un qui a
réussi à faire tourner les parties de
son côté mais mais mais mais mais mais
mais qui s'accroche et qui revient sans
arrêt dans le match mais qui est bien
avec avec l'intention de le gagner ce
match
alors qui est b5 logique il peut avoir
l'idée de mettre le cavalier en d6 et
devenir rebondir en attaquant le fou et
la tour mais qu'avait lieu 8 ou ac qui
joue solide 1 tout est protégé côté côté
américain les bases arrières sont
protégés ont bougé trois peut-être ont
chassé un côté à côté américain du à six
ont renvoyé lazare badjan chez lui
retourne dans ton camp les pièces
blanches n'ont rien à faire sur la 5eme
ranger est ouest et qui fait avancer sa
position maintenant et ce l'est qui veut
réagir
forcément il veut pas il veut pas
laisser le laser y revenir dans la
rencontre
car l idée d un cavalier 6
alors là c'est vrai que pour ma mais
c'est pas facile via pas y'a rien à
toucher la pièce les pièces noires sont
vraiment bien placé ses 4,5 ou que
j'aime beaucoup
maintenant que lecavalier a disparu de
la casse c3 c4 qui est faible et avec
ses 4 on met la pression sur quatre et
qui est pro 4 jouer et qui est étranger
3 maintenant qui va arriver cabanieu 5
avec une paire de fou qui va être
monstrueuse même et s'est pas fait parce
que il ya un peu le pion des six encore
un peu faible
surprise peut-être qu'on pourrait
essayer de remettre l'auto en c4 alors
on préfère évidemment les noirs mais la
position n'est pas morte aux cavaliers 3
et d'un match 4 car il sait remettre le
pion des 5
il est bien resté un cd qui a eu cinq
essais ktk et des katja dlc 1 4 qui
peuvent arriver
c'est un kafka 13,3 pour tout enfoncée
donc
est-ce que c'est parti pour les
obligeraient les noms comme surtout
reprend ya x 6 mai dame prend et x huit
on va avoir du mal lama mais a résisté
et ouais c'est qui va pour jouer f5 f4
beaucoup prochain
car les d4 c'est très bien joué aussi à
une union ces deux en l'air dam des
trois ils résistent pour ces trois red
hat en dames france et 3 a pris à huy à
temps et sur d'un prince et rang c'était
quoi le problème
ah oui il n'y a rien qui peut reprendre
ses trois pardon je pensais camaïeu 2
qui prend le 2 vous prend ces trois
juste pour montrer ça c'était peut-être
bien il y avait encore des 4 mais en
réalité il y avait un quart à liège
trois échecs
encore plus fort et ouais c qui a ramené
la tour ans et cette vie reste
simplement un petit on est de plus
ça va être très dur à tenir pour les
blancs
mais puis en des cats est peut-être là
tout en c3 un an leur tour f 4l voit pas
et au 5e tour ces trois maintenant
beffou pro f3 puis on part f3 et on sait
c'est chose faite il faut 5 bien joué
c'est toujours pas fini mais bon le truc
c'est que ce mec-là participent pas du
tout aux jeux il a fait retour à 5
maintenant au tour ces trois quand même
position est difficile pour les blancs
avec le four b3 qui peut pas participer
au jeu
mais les noirs ne peuvent pas échanger
les dames où est ce que cette finale la
gagne je suis passion qu'elle gagne
je suis pas sûr qu'elle gagne il faut
qu'ils créent des pions passé lié pour
qu'elle gagne mais ce qui peut le faire
il veut fouet au 8 mai lappion prend
appui on croit qu'ils veulent faire f
maintenant mais ça se doit être nul en
g3 fou prend alors à me ranger deux fois
eux deux il va la tenir très bien joué a
bien joué ma mais attendre whaou 3
fais monter le pion mais de toute façon
même si le roi me re 3 c'est pas grave
il va prendre quatre ouais c'est bon mam
et qui la tient ouais choix un choix
étrange de wesley qui a trop voulu
assurer le coup voilà maintenant le fou
vient ici aller retour et c'est fini
bien joué les tontons bien jouer pas
mais qui résiste à une position qui
semblait terminée il sait il s'est
accroché de folie et il a tenu à les ce
qu'on va retourner à l'éminent tigre une
fête cette fois ci ça peut ça peut
transposer éventuellement dans dc
mi-chemin en cernant le tigre une tête
je fais une super partie des rares sur
la chaîne times andy ciao
c'était un tournoi fin d'année à dubaï
je sais pas où en 2000 je sais pas en
tu auras qui jouent en descend avec une
magnifique partie que j'avais analysé et
qui était très sympa j'ai grandi ici sur
un bea
alors comment on va continuer notre ami
m'a mais ici en foot franck opposé une
nouvelle fois et ouais c'est qu'ils se
barrent n'ya pas pouvoir jouer tempo
comme quoi elle est sous pression à 1
c'est vraiment un magnifique match entre
les deux hommes qui se rendraient mon
coup pour coup
les parties relâcher la pression
exactement donc après henri iv et g4 ou
g5 et ça développe l'emploi on va voir
comment les joueurs vont attaquer les
rois sar est extrêmement intéressant 3
jouez qui contrôle un peu les cases
il ya quand même ses deux pions sans
trou pour les blancs qui semble
dangereux
france 3 prend 2,4 peut-être mais on
serait très affaiblissant pour le roi
les cars et les 1/4 aussi
faire tout half est
je pas trop compris en toile châteauguay
pas mal placé et oui des fois cette des
machins il faut et 6
c'est sympa il veut préparer une attaque
et cavalli ac à judy tête de la dame qui
rentre c'est une partie à mon avis très
important il reste combien salvatrice
bigas riesling naturel porn qu'il a
réellement ok pourquoi pas assez sots
qui parle de mamediarov j'écris ce sont
donc à prévoir
enfin les fallait comprendre que 5
si on prend le 5.1 5.5 à faire du tout
on sait ça
c'est tellement compliqué les mecs
et toi
chris prix stables dame 17
wild bar
qui c'est qu'a t il fait pousser 4
pouces et quatre sets dont je sais pas
mais ça ne paraît pas trois années pour
mam et ça en fait
le roi est bien caché puisque ya plus
tout cas ce droit pour attaquer sur
cases noires et fou j'ai quatre sages
avaient raté
tellement compliqué cette histoire
je pense que tu vas me faire pousser
quatre fous price est et on prend deux
tour d'hier fut finalement c'est une
terre y est j'ai pas lu et désolé mec
j'ai raté cette tactique de l'enfer où
j'ai capté et éreinté par sow d'ailleurs
aussi tout casser c'est du très lourd un
fou 4le par food et 5
ouais je trouvais intéressant de la part
de wesley tu vas récupérer sa qualité ce
avec le roi de mam et pas forcément en
grande forme
il part sur cases noires est ce que dan
des deux est un coup ici pour menacer
dam des 4es dame prend des six à
mesdames d2 et qui prend 1,4 dans le
17h17 on n'a pas de fond f6 échec
intermédiaires qui repart avec le fonds
est roi et il veut food et 4 il veut
découper droits sur cases noires c'est
bien jouer une nouvelle fois fou des
quatre il faudrait peut-être un coup de
tours non il va mettre le roi ici alors
kf5 ce qui va prendre à 7
ouais il le fait prend le pion le roi
noir qui finalement se fait découper sur
les diagonales c'est marrant à les
prendre à karachi reprend la kalach g4
il va peut-être le prendre à revers sur
la colonne ouverte
attention c'est très tendu ou essai qui
doit qui doit trouver les coûts
peut-être mais un dames 2 pour menaces
et ouais enfin le fou qui va revenir en
d4 lecavalier qui pourra peut-être venir
ans et 6 pour couvrir ça va être tendu
tout retour 17 il passe de l'autre côté
tours 8
le fou peut-être en d4 la dame la dame
au sein qui prend le cul en b cette
cavale et dessin car sur ton problème
c'est être proche d'eux y a des il ya
des menaces de partout où elle sait qui
va devoir être chaud le fou qui peut pas
revenir aux des 4000 à tous
3 qui courent tour 4 pour attaquer le
pion le pion qui avance à ya pas de
cavalier 3 le fou qui veille au grain
allez voir qu'ils vont récupérer le pion
g5 ça va être très tendu les mecs food
et 4 qui arrive et le pion acquis par le
fou qui est vraiment impérial h 5 à 5 h
4 à 6 mais il abandonne là mais non il
est tombé à elle c'était trop dur
d'arrêter espions ah ouais c'est
vraiment vraiment une
une belle fin de partie ou est ce
faisceau qui fait mal aux wesley so qui
fait mal qui reprend trois points
d'avance à elle fait mal ça là pour
m'amener à wesley qui qui envoyaient du
jeu un m'avait qui en sur mam et qui en
sueur emma mais qui va jouer un grand
vide à mike à trois noms c'est c'était
beau c'était beau sérieusement belle fin
de partie et ouais c'est ce qui qui
maintient son avance à plus de plus
trois mais ça on s'est plutôt en faveur
des blancs d'avoir joué à troyes dans
joueurs de position
c'est toujours ça leur est toujours bien
parce que si je pense pas que ce soit
très utile lors que à trois ça peut
servir
donc il reste combien de temps il reste
treize minutes 30 alors à se récupérer
les caméras avec notre petit heure et
demie comment faire maintenant on va pas
s'embêter
sac mais c'est un vrai problème ça non
sur food et 6 6 e 5 et qu'elle prend ses
700 à paramé à 3 les listes est plus
utile sinon il pourrait y avoir foule et
quatre échecs et rock où il y aurait des
trucs encore mais à 3 h 6 e dans les
ouvertures à d4 d5 c'est plus utile pour
les plans mais c'est bien joué de la
part de mam et donc il fait sac puis le
mans obligé mais c'est complètement
foutu après ouais ça joue encore un vous
prend vous des six
et c'est rare que c'est qu'à valider
cinq marches mais là c'est le cas
j'aurais bien que mal que mam elle
emporte un an celle là parce que ça
permettrait ça permettrait d'avoir un
beau minaret bruno hubert une belle
passe d'armes en bulles est donc ce
serait sympa
donc que 5 fu d ici c'est logique je
pensais qu'ils allaient faire fou prend
1,5 perso il va voir récupérer le fion
c4 mais quatre ans prises mais ça pas
être si simple puisque à faire un coup
comme f3 et je ne sais pas en tout cas
tout prendre comme ça il va se laisser
reprendre 4 ares qui va prendre quatre
maintenant pour défendre ici tout en
sachant deviez pas gâté dames 2 qui
prend la prise est forcément est
peut-être il va prendre le 4 maintenant
et sur dame deux des cinq et manière
assez incroyable la peinture noire
wesley et la d5
ou pas d'ailleurs nancy quand même quand
même quand même j et pourquoi pas parce
que tu as le foot cases blanches et
était peut-être content d'avoir un pion
sur noir était quand même très heureux
d'avoir le cavaliere 4 et il y arrive
bien tapé ici et sur d'un pseudo et
prendront des cas probablement il se
laissera prendre et il aura un petit
problème d'activité mais il devrait
pouvoir tenir
mais c'est embêtant ça parce que nous on
est plutôt pour les plans pas qu'on soit
plus pour ma mère attendait pas
d'apprendre à d'apprendre et 4 x 3
pardon cavaliers revient et roy achats
ont soudain prend des quatre gnafu prend
1,7 et sur dame prend b2 fou prend des
six allers ce qu'on peut faire
dam des deux quais avec et venir en aide
5 les versions qu elle n 5
il va probablement faire cavalier f5
non il fait tout huit semaines 1 tour 5
peut arriver non pour faire tout il
prend h6 alors sa chance et que ça
marchait pas ouais c'est exactement la
honte que j'avais calculé et je voyais
pas de jeu pour les blancs parce que le
cavaliere vie angers7
j'ai l'impression que c'est complètement
pipeau et la dame vers des canaux
ouais mais car ils agissent à kg cette
dame h7 d'accord et c'était très bien
joué en réalité un d'un prend b2 c'était
très bien joué de leur match 5
du coup il a défendu comme ça sur des
registres saddam prend des 5 alors
maintenant il peut pas gagner le pion
par mary leur tour b4g 4l tombé 4 des 5
des cas pardon f4 intermédiaire est sûre
d'un logiciel qui veut échanger prendre
bessette est maintenant tombée trois
tons g3 c'est fini c'est matt ou pas il
défend encore roll mais qu'est ce qu'il
est bon et cela c'est un défenseur mais
deux premières de première zone
il est incroyable il est incroyable en
défense où un vaisseau
c'est impressionnant les défenses qui
met ses impressionnants les amis c'est
vraiment incroyable
c'est incroyable et beau à la fois je
vais être la tour en d3 probablement un
an dame ces cas-là il a joué pour gagner
il est incroyable et ses sauts il va
remettre laurent h6 ça c'est bien joué
de la part de de mam et qui réagit en
menaçant m'as tu en as est ok il veut
pas nul non plus il y en a pas il y en a
aucun des deux qui a vu là nul mais il
joue avec le feu ma mère ça va faire une
huile au final et dames 5 qui c'est dur
à calculer il joue vraiment avec le feu
et on prend un f4 à c'est quoi le
problème
j'en sais rien mais là c'est sûr les
amis à main mais qu'à jouer au con quand
même un faux faux faux faux leur faut le
dire prend tous les risques et ça se
solde finalement par une nulle alors est
ce qui va encore rester du temps il
reste encore six minutes
incroyable comme parti on sait ce qu'ils
commencent par à trois univers t4 non et
oui mais ya pas eu accès soit une plume
à la main mais il joue pas bien il joue
pas à 3,6
c'est julien
c'était vraiment joli donc c'est
peut-être la dernière partie de 3 + 1 et
ensuite on enchaînera avec on enchaînera
avec le bullet mais vu que les parties
durent ça pourrait ça pourrait bien être
la dernière
et merci pour les pour les concurrents
sur la vidéo de ce matin mais j'ai
toujours du mal à comprendre pourquoi
c'est c'est pas toujours les meilleures
vidéos qui sont plus vus c'est important
le titre l'actualité mais c'est souvent
pas les meilleures vidéos les vidéos
d'actu celle de ce matin était vraiment
bien j'espère pouvoir préparer d'autres
c'est pas toujours facile
donc x 6 c'est peut-être la meilleure
vidéo du mois finalement non je pense
que vous en avez pensé
mon principe est au sein d'accor
il revient et nabeul 2 bon ça a l'air
d'être un peu insipide
ça fait les affaires de wesley après 1,2
de refaire une nulle et surtout si
réussi à manger le chronomètre talent
bullet j'ai l'impression que ma vie
commence à fermer les yeux quand il a
des tout-petits de ma vie où c'est une
impression chanson qui fatigue
amel est déconnecté d'accord payé de
retour non sens qui fatigue
alors
et j'ai ici ce qu'est qui veut rebondir
le f 4 5 qui bloque la connexion à la
casse 9,4
on peut pas dire que le match
d'aujourd'hui sont un match soporifique
1 parce que tous les gens ont senti le
c'était beau dire ça non mais on peut
pas lire c'est vraiment un match
intéressant kébé 5 peut-être ici pour
partir vers des six
ben bella wesley qui aujourd'hui envoyer
du jeu hein
les deux joueurs et la entame 4 ça se
passe comment assez curieux 5e saint
quirc hargneuse cinq médiateurs qui se
prennent un cas et 17 à un moment donné
mais à sa banque et ses quatre actions b
5e rang à cinq tours à six qui est p 3c
choix
c'est chaud et donc les menaces dames
quatre menaces qui est paré b3 il
consolide tu es peut-être des fous
problème de souffrance et 4 et là au
prochain les blancs veulent faire h3 sur
quoi faudra claquer en m21 donc h6 fou
des deux qui a toujours h3 qui m'a slim
a claqué en f2
quand une partie des plus tendues vie
reste plus qu'une minute dans cette dans
cette cadence
donc il semble qu'on aille jusqu'au bout
du chrono dans cette partie 1 4 d'accord
il vient affaiblir le cavalier c4 donc
sur h3 il va vouloir claquer sur f2 et
vous fait en b3 à la fin pour attaquer
encore le cavalier qui pourraient
rejaillir vers des six meilleurs et
peut-être par an dans les cinq ans les
flics et p2 mais maintenant il n'y a pas
eu cinq en l'air dans les jurys avec
l'ordi et paquets les pages trois là
quand même raté un truc fondamental je
crois b5 pour céline numéro anne laure
10 mai cavalli b2 que dit leur livrer
jusqu'à et prend 1,5
ils le voient pas ça incroyable il a
oublié que le cavaly c4 protège étions
les deux joueurs ont oublié
il y avait juste qu'ils allaient prendre
5 mais ça c'est dur dans le feu de
l'action quand tu joues et m6
faire 5 mais maintenant il a de chance
incroyable
il ya une fois 3 qui reste en l'air quel
dommage pour ma mais quel dommage pour
mam et qui était qui rate il fait une
belle partie et il rate le plus facile
il rappelé le plus simple dans cette
partie et ça tourne à plus 4 pour wesley
à mma mais qui qui réalise un beau match
et qui cracotte un tout petit peu près 2
fin de partie qui se passe mal il y
aurait égalité mais c'est wesley le plus
solide qui place des défenses en face
aussi de faire donc voir faire une
petite pause et on sera de retour très
bientôt
[Rires]
[Musique]
les mecs on va repartir
pour les bullet on a vu un sur le
tableau que le vainqueur du match sera
l'adversaire de maxime vaches et la
garde au prochain tour et demain vous
aurez les deux mature à levon aronian
fille ruth jacky sera un match très
sympa et que fable commentera je prends
à 18 heures et ensuite dans la foulée le
match sera pas commenté en français mais
ce sera à retenir gris choo donc ouais
c'est ce qui a plu ce 4l et le joueur
azéri mam est donc avec les blancs qui a
déjà filé un pion mais c'est un gambit
dame tout ça est bien connu et il faut
absolument marquer là pour ma mais il
faut marquer les deux premières parties
au moins faire mener 3 à revenir à deux
points assez rapidement essayé de faire
l'effort par la suite mais ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que pour le moment dans
le jeu très rapide c'est plutôt plutôt
le joueur américain qui a dominé avec
une défense de fer une défense vraiment
impressionnante de la part de west et
sow mais peut-être qu'à tout moment le
mur wesley peu à peu commencé à
craqueler et l'eau s'infiltrait et venir
faire un gros dégâts des eaux qui qui
enlèvera la peinture ce qui serait assez
pénible quand même pour pour wesley donc
du coup les blancs qui ont le centre là
en d 4 5 et 6 mam ait réussi à gagner le
pion c4 qu'il aura un pion plus mais
malheureusement il ne réussit pas la
dame hkmg trois dames g5 h4 ça semble
aller un double attaque damage 4g trois
dames h3 il va menacer m'attend j'ai de
aiai année fouet fin défend tout damage
5 et vous prend 1,7
non pourquoi pas fou prend aux aides
attendait qu'elle était à yahvé dame f3
aidé à machin matola l'or mais quelle
défense
mais quelle défense de wesley so qui une
nouvelle fois trouvé à y trouve
il trouve la défense ouest les nouvelle
fois et l'impressionnant à le damage
froide après faire penser d'un match 5
fouille s'aide d'un f3 pour jouer sur la
diagonale
c'est impressionnant
alors on a un genre de française
finalement avec wesley qui va essayer de
faire le break avec les blancs à l'ema
mais qui joue et variantes avec le g5
c'est bien joué car elle est enfin g4
qui va partir et peut-être il va les
prendre en d4 alors après la position
après d'un projet 4 à mon avis est mieux
pour les blancs à la dame qui va
s'infiltrer vergès est le fou qui va
venir vers h 6 mais bon il ya du jeu ça
va être hyper tactique mais c'était
vraiment impressionnant il faudra être
solide 1 pour maxime au prochain tour en
quarts de finale parce que wesley je
sais pas ce qui lui arrive mais il m'a
l'air d'avoir vraiment step up dans ces
formats déjà l'année dernière
déjà l'année dernière il avait vraiment
été excellent et cette année il m'a
l'air d'être encore plus fort et ce qui
est ce qui pourra être au dessus de 2
n'a qu'à en k2 en cas de retour en
finale il faudra voir parce que tu n'as
qu'à il a eu l'air friable hier soir
face à face à face à d'oberhof les
wesley qui impressionne
les années passent et n'a qu'à ne
rajeunit pas naka petit à petit qu'ils
avancent dans l'âge soki encore je ne
sais pas quel âge il a exactement il est
encore jeune très jeune même donc d4
d'un prince est qu'ils aient bougé le
client est roi et ça m'a l'air d'être
vraiment intéressant cependant il ya
peut-être pu faire paître qui rôde un
ton g8 tourache 8
ouais
du coup non maman qui font pas le père
pète il aurait peut-être du faux-pas
faut pas forcer les choses c'est comme
quand on dit souvent ce pas parce qu'on
est derrière au score
il ya encore le temps qu'il faut tous
risques et sur une partie où on n'est
pas très bien ce que la position me
semble quand même plus agréable pour les
blancs avec un cac qui a peut-être
jaillir en 4 ou en d4
il prend prise torah et ouais et il ya
le tour prend 1,7 qui arrive au mesdames
prend p4 qui contre tempo d'âme des uns
là ça joue vraiment bien et sur dame c4
peut-être tour quatre dames c5 a surtout
reprend ainsi si modane problèmes d'eau
d'un projet de maths d'un f3 cours et
mona seif 7 mai pourra pas prendre les
six mais menaçait pts 7
et le fou allez va pouvoir prendre f7 et
prendre un set je pense il commence par
panda cette épreuve 7 et tours b 1 dames
f4 sur d'amd katia satwa 4 3 c3 qui
avait qu'a prise le 4 mai maintenant il
n'y a plus la pression sur ce pion
detroit il renouvelle la menace d'un
problème de ces incroyables cette partie
le roi qui en c3 dont g8 il enlève la
tour qui était en prise dames 1
des deux c'est le pion des qui protège
elle est incroyable cette partie est
l'extraordinaire prise prise leur
handicap qui est toujours
il repart il repart oh là là c'est
magique et peut-être d'un lève 3 qui peu
rodé maintenant qui menace d un dame est
un projet de 2005 pour prendre les cinq
ans il reprend sur g5 sur échec
incroyable gk h4 est d'amener zack hall
alors et tout reprendre et c'est un pion
pranger cinq échecs et il attend de
reprendre la dame au ce coup de folie de
hkd de wesley so au la vitesse
d'exécution boîtier qui avait
probablement vitam f3 et qui a fait h4
tempo hommes et c'est une formule 1
c'est pas vraiment le dame g5 en soi qui
est impressionnant il le trou mais c'est
qu'il avait sûrement prévu à l'avance
assez incroyable incroyable wesley so
démonstration vraiment quelle qu'elles
quel niveau en défense 2
la part du joueur américain oh là là
c'est incroyable ce cette défense de fer
quel délire le roi qui était monté il eu
fini c'est vraiment joli
or là on a vraiment le droit à des à des
belles joutes un incroyable pour le
moins angoissé qui prend cinq points
d'écart
il y as combien de temps on va regarder
ça rs 23 minutes et là en plus il fait
un il fait vraiment tourner le chrono
puisque les partis sont longues et à la
main mais qui est dans le dur en laye
doit vraiment gagner mais il semble
simplement moins fort que wesley so même
si dans cette partie où est cité a un
peu fait n'importe quoi
emma mais qu avoir un peu recoller mais
à mais bon il va recoller à moins 4 au
mieux il a vraiment été solide un
citoyen de faire un fou aux 7 qui est
produite en france et 4 s'est pas pris
les meilleurs tout elle fit cavalier 5/4
e 2
non mais c'est beau les échecs quand on
sait jouer comme ça les amis
c'est beau et ce qu'ils pensent un dame
prend à f2 roy prend car et j'ai quatre
échecs
voilà mais ça marche pas fou h 4 à effet
d'amener 4
mais à mon avis ça va être très chaud
pour ma mais cette histoire il m'a
encore la gagne et sow et il va marquer
de son sceau le match kg 8 tempo il
avait vu aux siens c'est ça qui est
impressionnant c'est que foix iii et et
tempo il réagi adam 3 il voit tout un
pays
il a un temps d'avancé sur ma mais il
est il est juste plus fort tactiquement
ils le montrent il mange un peu comme
une comme une boîte de sardines
saupiquet ça ça ça passe ça il a descend
très vite ma mais qui va pas qui va plus
pouvoir revenir mais ce qui nous a fait
une démonstration
ouais c'est vraiment il mériterait qu'on
lui offre une petite bouteille de saumur
pour la peine à la fin du match
non c'est eux c'est vraiment vraiment
une belle prestation ça fait ça fait
plaisir à voir
on est là pour voir des beaux échec et
aujourd'hui on a été servis ce soir on a
été servis et ceux des matches comme ça
de ce pitch est ce qu'on veut voir un
l'aîné peau danielian les deux profs
fnaca et tout ça c'est pas honnêtement
c'est pas assez parce qu'être plus beau
mais là ce qu'on ce qu'on voit ce qu'on
regarde aujourd'hui c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment agréable
on a peut-être perdu sauvignon et je
voyais aussi favori mais pas aussi bon
en bulles est ce honnête il avait été
excellent l'année dernière contre n'a
qu'à en finale pour ceux qui ont vu le
match a été tout reprend des cinq qui
est prendrait 5 fu b52 raté les choses
un meilleur mais l'assaut qui est
vraiment en démonstration elle a
vraiment été bons souvent elles étaient
excellents bullet l'an dernier en finale
contre maca il avait eu il avait réalisé
une démonstration à je crois que a
surtout réussi six as j'ai trois ans
ferme la dame
donc ton coin f4 va être joué et j'ai
trois quand même
et là c'est beau parce que dame g5 et
apprendre à me ranger 3 il y aura tour
g2 qui contrecoup sur la colonne j'ai
donc y aura pas t3f 4 et ça va faire
plus 8
wesley qui s'envole wesley qui s'envole
ou +7
ça fait plus est mais là plus est ma
béquille mais qui coule mais c'est pas
mal mais qui aura
qui aura lâché le match on s'est
vraiment sow qui a été so so formidable
impressionnant bon alors maintenant il
va gérer la fin de son match c'est sa
fin de match par dont il a pu cette fois
il peut il peut gérer tranquillement le
match est plié
mais de quelle manière il a été prié de
quelle manière il a été fouillé les amis
il aurait été solidaire summum de sa
forme
impressionnant
impressionnant pour et c'est
impressionnant non on peut pour y aller
voir après le match le sommelier pour
pour lui offrir une belle bouteille il a
mérité ce sera pas saugrenue comme comme
cadeau ranger 4 5 1 il va fixer le plus
rapide 2 qui va les prendre maintenant
il va ramener la tour en a deux c'est
parfait c'est parfait va pouvoir passer
chez sosh
il va pouvoir passer chez sosh est
branché 6 3 5 qui arrive mais c'est
peut-être raté là il aurait peut-être dû
attendre un tempo pour faire ça parce
qu'un set
il est d'origine philippine saut
non
en page 4 bref trois tours h35 bêtement
ça va ça va tenir tranquille annonce
assez bien joué
j'ai 4 3 3 4 c'est bien jouer alors il
va pas prendre le pion attendait il
fallait non ça va ça va aller c'est un
mec qui joue bien aussi
le roi qui est coupé du mauvais côté ça
doit aller pour pour mam et le roi qui
est du mauvais côté il est par exemple
côté ça va gagner belles belles belles
techniques en tout cas de ma mais qui va
maintenant faire un pont du sénat sow
qui lui joue jusqu'au bout après ces
jeux or il al avantage au score il a
sept points d'avance il veut faire
encore quelques coups ouais sais je sais
je prie n'aurait pas besoin de ça pour
gagner mais je le comprends mais qui
essaye de faire économique le moins de
coups possible
je renvoie ce qui se passe là
aso fair play il a vu que ma mère avait
un souci de deux connexions quoi il a
décidé d'abandonner sympa s'en va parce
que je passe pour voir ce qui se passait
mais sow qui avons donné qu'il n'y a pas
qu'à pas donné l'occasion à son
adversaire de tomber sur un problème de
connexion c'est pas un sauvage c'est pas
un sauvage ou un bug d'ordinateur ou
quoi il a dessiné de de laisser le point
et c'est tout à son honneur
c'est c'est ça qu'on aime voir
donc
non mais c'est assez sympa de sa part
cette partie ça donne quoi c'est encore
là mais qui domine
ouais ce soit avec six points d'avancé
exactement soit + 6 ce qui va suffire il
reste combien de temps en 4
il va reprendre de la tête du cavalière
et il va jouer
il veut jouer les cinq maintenant demain
et demain je suis tenant sa est sportif
espérant qu'ils commentent 1 demain ces
femmes
moi je suis tranquille il n'y a pas de
français cette année il y avait gf
encore une défaite de so so qui passe à
+5 sow qui passe à +5
mais il reste onze minutes 55
ça devrait suffire au pire il peut faire
un peu tourner là pour nous le vrai il
n'ya pas ya pas péril en la demeure
les grands trucs et pâtes et riz pour
les blancs il craque un peu la cerise a
été fair play mais il est mal payé
y a pas de justice dans ce monde est de
faire plus a jamais fait gagner des
matches après sa manière il a quand même
une grosse avance mais un peu que celle
inverse en fait ces soutiens les noirs
pardon à force que ça tourne je me suis
planté non non ça va il était très bien
juste y y laisser un peu le jeu à son
adversaire alors d échanger c'est pas il
est pas si impérial que ça dans cette
partie il a un peu baissé de rythme
ménage 5 créée quand même des menaces
maintenant ton g4 est bien tôt gecas la
non aux imams et qui prend les trois
autres projets deux tours de fouet f3
ajoutons g13 ray donc ça va non c'est
mam et karaté son ouverture
je me suis inverser les couleurs donc il
reprend +6 et elle avec dix minutes à
jouer
quoi qu'il arrive c'était déjà fini à
plus 5 mais bon en cas de on ne sait pas
quoi
ouais il faudra vraiment une sommité des
échecs pour pour le sortir du tournoi
sans un joueur vraiment chevronné il
pourra il pourrait remporter le tour
dont il fait partie des grands favoris
joueur qui peut qui peuvent prétendre à
ce titre c'est pas un outsider
est ce qu'il est mais non mvele qui
jouera contre ce au prochain tour qui
font partie des favoris à mpl gritche
louxor nakamura
tout ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même les joueurs un peu au dessus mbl
qui aura fort à faire contre sow est ce
que chez toi en live de temps en temps
mais les arénas king dès vendredi
donc évidemment en termes de
commentaires et ça on est un petit peu
moins chaud dans le sens où le score et
fait maintenant m haies saut directe en
quarts c'est domanova et je sais pas où
tu es tu vas voir tu vas avoir du
d'anaqua tu vas avoir tu vas avoir du
talus lourd de partout de toute façon
donc à l'ecam son parti j'ai c'est de
refaire la technique nous permet de les
récupérer
ça me fait nul on a de toute façon les
joueurs qui savent que le résultat efira
et suit minute tu fais une arena
vendredi
bah écoute la sueur en vacances donc je
suis pas sûr peut-être que oui peut-être
que non ça dépend si j'ai envie ou pas
quand même donc vous aurez pas mal de
live en chaise comme du coup ils vont
prendre
ils vont prendre ça pour faire les
commentaires demain après demain samedi
et dimanche vous pourrez suivre tout ça
les speech est ce la finale de la coupe
du monde vous aurez un petit peu tout
photo 3 pouces et 5 je pense peut-être
non
non mais le tableau il va être dur pour
tout le monde on a great choquant car
c'est pas un cadeau artemiev au premier
cours c'est pas un profane ya que des
monstres avant ce tournant nepomniachi
ce n'est pas un cadeau
enfin tu veux prendre qui en car en fait
de facile c'est peut-être duda le joueur
théoriquement plus facile mais il est
signé grille tout cas la saison dernière
je sais pas moi c'est surtout sur le
premier tour que je critique un peu la
compétition il ya quelques matches qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être mais sinon on peut
faire un tour j'ai un prize-pool et
quatre n'ont en effet amy fois je sis et
tour g3 tourcoing f3 ou tour f1 même
tour f1 c'est sympa un premier rue
non mais moi je refuserais je veux le
premier tour juste prendre un nul ça
fait une nouvelle nul donc la safi par
quelques nus les récits minutes de jeu
c'est fait chirurgien à rognac barbarian
favori pour moi après on verra pas
résoudre en aucun cas jouer un match de
trois heures et demie contre un mec de
ce niveau là c'est une torture tu te
fais une milliers c'est humiliant
ses 1001 chevaux pur en bullet bave ça
dépend de la connexion darron jan cerny
redis avec une collection en papier
mâché comme il l'avait fait quand il
avait joué le championnat du monde de
bulles est way sera difficile on s'en
fout pas savoir n'est pas fou g8 ici à
calais des trois échecs qui viendra
couper la connexion
mon cas et d'effroi way
en dames prévu 4 et ça va gagner non
c'est quoi la défense fouet f5 arrête à
mach 4 francs dame c4 et ça à faire un
père pète c'est joli ça attention hein
c'est pas du pu l'être
curan un + 0 c'est bien plus un c'est
cadence un peu différente donc les nuls
s'enchaînent en bullet avec des jolies
perpète et donc plus quatre minutes de
jeu
en tout cas je vous remercie tous de
repasser ce joli mois de de 7 ans
accompagnés je crois que j'ai exprimés
quasiment tous les jours vous avez été
tout le temps nombreux donc je vous
remercie pour ça ou l'ena il veut vont
continuer donc avec encore quatre jours
de direct avec chaises comme et après on
se retrouvera je crois me et fin octobre
pour ensemble donc avec moi pour les
pour les demi finales la finale du
championnat du monde de 2 960 qui sera
super le grand prix fidh qui sera
décisif pour les candidats le grand prix
fina hambourg et le grand prix fille de
tel-aviv
donc on va avoir énormément de live de
qualité et de toute façon je vous ferai
un blog des vacances on va se marrer
avec ludwig
donc
on va voir ce que ça donne
une blague ferdinand décrit l'attaqué
est aussi naturel que le sourire d'un
bébé enfin d'un bébé sympa c'est moi qui
ai pu lire une connerie comme ça non
c'est vrai qu'il ya du sahel c'est moi
qui ai dû me dire enfin d'un bébé sympa
ce que le vix rend la valise non
violence aversion pour les vacances à
flasse moscou début octobre c'est pas le
top il va neiger mais bon ce sera sympa
et n'a malheureusement je n'ai pas les
digues avec moi mais les caméras les uns
reperdu immédiat mal on va devoir finir
son caméras les mecs pensent pas très
grave un pour les deux minutes qui
restent donc ça va probablement être la
prochaine à dernière je peux jeter un
oeil sur le live est officiel de toute
façon on voit bien que c'est anecdotique
1,7 fin de cette fin de match il reste
encore une minute vingt donc il en
restera une derrière
la solution sa ducroire résonne partout
de nouveau mais une pièce de plus pour
wesley tu vas peut-être tombé là quand
même
ouais il tombe parce qu'il est pas tout
point de vue évidemment elle fit g8
dames et donc on va arriver à la
dernière partie
[Musique]
donc
bien partie du match voilà on a fait le
point sur une petite question quoi c'est
le moment je vous enverrai en raid sur
la chaîne officielle à la fin du match
pour que vous ayez les interviews si
vous étiez nouveau ici n'hésitez pas à
mettre un petit follow à suivre la
chaîne
ça fait toujours plaisir
sur une dernière attaque rossi pourrait
lever à dussault et écoute je vais jouer
les oiseaux de mauvaise augure je m sow
favori il m'a impressionné
est-ce que je l'aï pas prêt non vraiment
ce que je fasse une un live préparation
de bagages mais non
donc
la tour 1 et aurillac et prendrait si ce
que j'avais vu qu'il ya cavaliers de cet
échec et qu'il prend des 8
c'était le petit chipeau et ça va finir
là-dessus finalement avec un seau
supérieur dans le petit jeu tactique est
ouest et qui l'emportent
on verra on verra demain le match
aronian firoud déjà ça dépend de
beaucoup de choses
armes égales je pense que aronian est
quand même au dessus mais on verra ça il
ya beaucoup de facteurs qui peuvent
jouer en tout cas ce sera un match
intéressant vous pouvez suivre en direct
à partir de 18h et ce sera un match un
match agréable à suivre sera femme qui
vous le commentera et ce sera une belle
affiche
sur ce les mecs je crois qu'on a fait le
tour de tout pas beaucoup de personnes
qui rebondit si j'ai envie de dire mais
bon on a fait beaucoup de live vous êtes
fatigués et moi aussi
il ya beaucoup de fans d'asnières is a
way mais après il ya une fan et être
objectif un je ne sais pas appris à quel
point
à quel point alireza quand même un
regard de saint jean du top mondial 1
c'est ça un monde du coup après coup
t'es tu vous envoyer vers les interviews
c'est quand même ça qui est intéressant
je souhaitais à une bonne soirée je peux
être une mettre une petite page de pub
courte
du coup pour la fin petite coupure
publicitaire de 30 secondes et puis et
puis on enchaîne avec avec le live
américain jour merci d'avoir suivi et je
vous dis à très bientôt
charles tout le monde